Joe Biden is cancer
that's not an exaggeration
um well he had the cancer removed he's
probably got more I don't know but uh
Joe Biden had skin cancer removed from
his chest and I feel like the media is
going to come out and I'll go oh it's no
big deal you know it's just it's basal
cell carcinoma it's of the skin cancers
one of the most common and uh he he cut
him off you know they've been removed
they're not it's typically not fatal but
it can severely disfigure you and so
let's just put it simply Biden
has had his cancer removed the crazy
thing about it is last year Biden said
he had cancer and then the media
immediately came in to say no no no no
no no no he he misspoke he he said he he
meant to say he had cancer because
before he was president he also had skin
cancer removed so it's like all right
he's got plates in his brain he can't
talk straight he's got cancer yeah okay
you know whatever I guess in other news
apparently Andrew Tate has cancer so
that kind of sucks you know cancer is no
joke I feel bad I'm not here to rag on
Biden for having cancer but I think it's
an important thing to talk about and
agitate apparently has lung cancer which
is much more serious so we'll uh we'll
get into all of that and uh we got some
cultural stories too of just about
marriage and family things I think are
really interesting and a a woman
who had a bunch of cats was being
evicted from her home so she burned her
home to the ground with the cat with her
and the cats in it and I'm just thinking
like this is your future get married now
before it's too late and I'm only half
kidding we'll talk about that before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com click that join us button to
become a member and support our work
directly as a member you're our customer
see we don't have a whole lot of
sponsors we could all these big
companies want to sign Tim cast IRL they
want to buy out the company because they
want us to do like five to six ads per
show we do like five to six ads per
month and we didn't even do any ads last
month because I'd rather have you as
customers as members at timcast.com pay
what you will if you so choose and then
watching our members only content that
way when a paying member says I am
concerned about this thing we say okay
well you're the customer as opposed to a
big Corporation being like don't you say
naughty words because we're the customer
so if you become a member at timcast.com
you're supporting our endeavors you're
supporting our operation and you get
access to exclusive members only
segments Monday through Thursday live
and we are putting together a private
chat server where y'all can hang out as
members and then even call into our
uncensored after shows so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Chrissy Clark hello
hi thanks for having me yeah who are you
what do you do um not much no I'm
kidding I'm a reporter for the daily
call I have my own show reaction with
Chrissy Clark obviously and then I just
put out a new documentary called damage
the transit of America's kids which
talks a lot about detransitioners and
the medicalization that a lot of them
underwent right on well thanks for hang
out that should be fun we got a lot
hanging out hey everybody what's up Tim
thanks for having me on I am allad
aliyahu a reporter here for timcast news
what's happening Phil hi everybody I am
uh Phil Labonte lead vocalist for All
That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary hi and I'm Ian
Crossland I'm wild and crazy and
freakish all these things if you uh your
microphone you can tilt it towards your
face and then when you move around you
can carry it with you yeah this is more
comfortable yeah it's easier hi everyone
and we also have Kellen slay in it
that's right I'm back uh happy Friday
everyone uh Fridays are always the best
days in my opinion so let's get into it
this morning I interviewed Pete parata
formerly of The Offspring over at
youtube.com timcast for the culture War
podcast episode two and it went up late
it went up around 2 30 because our
internet completely went out this is
what happens we're in the middle of
nowhere and all of our backups were
failing so it actually took like an hour
to upload but it went up and it's really
interesting Pete perrotta of course was
replaced in the band of The Offspring
after 14 years because his doctor said
hey we recommend you do not get the
vaccine due to complications related to
Guillain-Barre syndrome and he went oh
okay all right he went to the band and
said hey guys I don't know if I can do
this the doctor says no and they're like
get out
so it's a bit more complicated than that
but we talked for a couple hours about
this and so much more it was a really
interesting conversation so if you're
interested to hear about that behind the
scenes there's also some really cool uh
insights into what it's like to be in a
internationally touring band when covid
happened and all of a sudden you're like
in some foreign country and they're like
hey everything's locking down you better
get out quick check that out youtube.com
timcast and uh let's jump into the first
story we got this from the
post-millennial breaking Biden has
cancerous tissue removed from chest a
statement from the president's physician
announced that Biden had a skin lesion
on his chest removed at Walter Reed
hospital in DC which was later tested
and found to be basal cell carcinoma a
type of skin cancer all right so that's
the that's the news you may be asking
because I don't want I don't want to
bury this I don't want to come out and
be like he's dying yes cancer no no hold
on
this is the Kelowna skin cancer center
clinic
Kelowna Skin Cancer Clinic I just looked
this up is basal cell carcinoma fatal
they say no
the risk of death is extremely low
however it has the potential to cause
significant disfigurement and that can
have a serious impact on your life the
prognosis is excellent so it's not like
Joe Biden is on his deathbed or anything
like that but the reason I think this is
this is important is because we had this
story a while ago where in July on July
22nd 2022 Joe Biden said he had cancer
he said where is it at he has his quote
here and he says you had to put on your
windshield wipers again literally your
oil stick off the window that's why I
and so damn many other people I grew up
grew up with have cancer and why can for
the longest time Delaware the highest
cancer rate in the nation
when he said that the media was like no
no no he meant he had it he had it well
apparently he didn't
I mean apparently this dude has
consistently had cancerous lesions on
his skin so I don't know
it's it's breaking news do you guys
think it's significant well I'm not
president has cancer it's definitely
significant I don't think it's it's not
surprising because he did tell us he had
cancer like last year but then the media
was like no no no also it's probably not
super uncommon for people that are you
know his age and in that kind of
stressful environment to develop some
sort of reaction stress reaction like I
think cancer can be brought in by stress
and diet as much as like I don't know
what Pharma is going to tell you it's
brought on by but a lot of times fixing
your diet can in my opinion skin cancer
is usually a product of sun exposure
usually but um yeah it's another like an
environmental stressor as well yeah
sorry to interrupt you no no it just
like my dad passed away at cancer in
like 20 years ago and it was melanoma
it's
you know it's not typical for people to
die but Joe Biden is from from skin
cancer but Joe Biden is old you know so
I I don't know that that this is is
something that is gonna often
but I imagine it's worth being honest
with the American people about I think
the biggest issue here is the fact that
again the media is is you know playing
doing the the pr role for the
administration remember that story about
Biden being in the shower and then
trying to trying to grab the dog's tail
and then slipping and breaking his foot
or whatever yeah yeah yeah everybody you
know uh watches everybody but a lot of
people thought that was cover for
something else so they could get him
into the hospital
oh he hurt his foot he's got to go to
the hospital and then really they were
doing the timeline on that on how long
he was in the hospital for yeah or like
I don't know when he was in I'm curious
I don't know but I mean if he if if they
can go in and remove cancerous tissue
that quickly I wonder if they've like
they're at the point where they're just
like look we can't pretend anymore like
yeah we just got to tell people the
truth this it's not the first time he's
had cancer removed but I don't know I'm
just ah the crazy thing is
at first I see the story about Biden
having cancer and I'm like okay well
it's serious no matter how serious the
cancer is but then I just think nobody
who
likes Joe Biden well nobody likes Joe
Biden but nobody who was on the left or
liberal cares the dude could like have a
heart attack on stage and they'd be like
well you know uh and they'd make an
excuse for it and then people on the
right don't believe he's actually in
charge anyway
so does anybody really care that Biden's
I do I care I don't like him but I care
for about him and I mean I mean
politically like is there any concern at
all so he's an 80 year old man and I
understand many people in the audience
aren't the biggest fans of Joe Biden but
I think we should be praying for this
man given that if he plots then it's
Kamala Harris so it's only getting worse
from here and it's going to get a lot
worse people think Joe Biden's
incompetent I think Kamal Harris is
twice as incompetent as Joe Biden so we
should be praying for this 80 year old
man Joe Biden used to know some stuff
Kamala Harris has never known a thing
ever
and yeah they're still trying to drop
her there's been a lot of beef between
um Biden and Kamal so I'd be keeping an
eye on her if anything because if
something happens to Biden uh I'd be
nervous that Kamal was involved yeah or
a sick Biden like a really not well guy
is makes way poorer decisions like an
unhealthy mind is the most dangerous
President we could have I don't care who
it is if someone's got a broken brain so
I want him to become healthy and soak in
the tub guys there's an old saying that
the Apple doesn't fall too far from the
tree and so when you look at Hunter
Biden as a human being you have to
wonder about his dad I was like I wanna
I wanna help I want to like these people
to become healthier I want Vladimir's
Lindsey to become healthier I want
Vladimir Putin to become healthier and
then I was like I want the Russian
soldier and the Ukrainian soldier that
are shooting at each other to both
become healthier and then I was
picturing two guys in a knife fight and
trying to get them to both become
healthier and I'm like I couldn't
at some point I can't heal both of them
when they're killing each other that's
right
give you one
like I can't I don't know who to like I
do want to like
Elevate and heal people but when they're
it's like I can't it's I couldn't like
spiritually do it I was like there's
some sort of uh blockade like blur so I
have an idea here I think there's
something wrong what I think we see
sometimes in politics is where we they
push politicians who are unhealthy to
continue running and continue their role
because there's a lot of people attached
to them and I think we saw that in the
case with I don't know exactly what's
going on with Dianne Feinstein but she
has shingles and she probably should
have retired a long time ago Joe Biden
doesn't seem totally competent John
fetterman probably didn't need to finish
running that campaign after he had the
stroke but it seemed that he was
pressured by his wife and others um
Chrissy what do you think about this
stuff yeah it's just I was thinking that
the whole Biden thing is so reminiscent
of what's going on with John fetterman I
just I genuinely know you're talking
about this with Ashley the other day too
like there's no way that man just has
depression there has to be something
else he's got to be covering up for
something else
um but at the same time you know I
counter or counteract myself because I'm
like there's no way his wife just left a
man that could be dying of something to
go to Canada unless she's like a
Stepford Wife you know like yeah I get
it though because if John's if he's
incapacitated and the kids are probably
so scared for their dad and so they're
like let's do something fun yeah it was
that Niagara Falls it wasn't like they
went to the Deep runaway it's New York
you know Niagara Falls right now I'm
thinking though like think about your
spouse is running in a primary they have
a stroke they aren't in the best of
health and the campaign is not an easy
thing to run there's a lot of pressure
it's a lot of stress reporters are
hounding you I was one of the reporters
hounding them and she was like no let's
stay in the race through the general and
one of the most contentious elections
the Senate races it's an extremely close
Senate race and that takes a toll on
your health so you have to think about
like what a lot of these people around
them are putting some of these
politicians through and you have to
worry if if Joe Biden is and again we're
praying that he is because if he does
plot or resign it's not getting better I
don't know I don't know if I I think
it'll be that different
I think Kamala Harris has a different
team around here I think they're
completely
you think Kamala Harris has a team
I mean yeah and I think she has a
different team around her that but think
that she's incompetent like she also did
very poorly across the country when she
was running for president I don't even
think she pulled well in California she
quit she quit before the California
primary so that way she didn't get so
she didn't get hosed and lose her entire
political career because she was gonna
she was gonna get trout in California by
Andrew Yang yeah I couldn't imagine
Kamala Harris interacting with different
world leaders too in a serious way she'd
just have that nervous laugh I don't
trust her with her hands on the nuclear
weapon I think that I'm kind of whether
it's Trump I mean I think Trump would do
a good job
but I gotta be honest you know we're
going to talk a little bit later about
this these uh this cat lady burning down
her house and then I just think about it
and I'm just like
maybe we just need some hard times man
I think we'll all be fine I think
everybody who listens to a show like
this is probably fine we got so many
people who are like look I bought
chickens I got got out of the city and
I'm just like I think most people will
be fine
and I think the reality is I wouldn't
want to pull up Bill Maher and be like
bring on the recession to get rid of
trump
but I would want to say something like
guys whether you want it to or not the
storm is a bruin and we can see the
clouds off on the horizon whether it
comes now or whether it comes tomorrow
you best get ready for it but you know
what that Storm's going to come and wash
away all of all this BS I've toyed with
the idea of let it get worse sooner so
that it can get better faster I don't
think it really works that way if you
let things get bad they get really bad
and out of control when things are out
of control the world economic Forum
creates a new government I'm not saying
to let things go to control I'm saying
brace yourself for the storm I'm not
saying whether it's Biden or Kamala that
storm's coming either way but let's
let's weather the storm the thing is
with from to Tim's point the more people
you have prepared for hard times and for
the storm or whatever like the less
impact the people have on the people
that are unprepared so the more people
you have that are prepared the more
capable they are of helping the people
that are unprepared so it's it's just a
good idea idea to you know have some
kind of ability to have to to fend for
yourself have some food stored up you
know have have a week or two maybe a
couple months depending on your your
ability you know but I'm just a lot of
people have chickens how do you defend
your chickens what's the best defense
electric fence uh mil-spec AR-15 so like
like actual guard on duty other Beyond a
guard under the electric fence a stud
rooster well for for cocktown we have an
electric fence and that mostly keeps it
the Predators though some of the
roosters have jumped over it because I
mean they're dumb and they're they're
looking for girls and there's no girls
but I don't blame them like if I was in
a big room full of dudes and they were
like outside's dangerous I'd be like
yeah but it's like oh nothing but dudes
in here but but if someone tries to
steal the chicken it's basically you
need a guard on duty
I mean depending on what's Happening I
wouldn't want to end a human being's
life over a chicken you know but if
we're talking about like the apocalypse
and you've got Banditos who are trying
to come and steal your food
and that could kill you and then you get
it you gotta think about that but but I
want to go back to my point my point was
just this
you see these videos of these like
morbidly obese Millennials and gen's
ears being like why do I have to have a
job I should be allowed to just sleep
all day and I'm kind of like
maybe life's too good you know what I
mean like there look right now and I'm
not talking about hard-working Americans
you got a dude working at a steel mill
who's barely scraping by
and you contrast that with morbidly
obese young people who are like I'm a
water drop
I'm not saying the dude that steel mill
needs a harder life I'm saying he's
already working hard she's already
working hard
I'm saying we got too many young people
who don't work hard at all extract from
the system vote for government to take
money from the people who are working to
give to people who aren't
you know people talk about how communism
is coming and uh we we played that video
the other day where this teacher talks
about socialism and she said she gives
her whole class a shared grade and then
the grade slowly go down because like
all the so the story was the students
were like socialism works and she said
okay then we'll average all of your
grades so nobody fails but nobody gets
an a either and they said great let's do
it the the hard workers who study really
hard get B's and the lazy people got
bees and so the lazy people were like
this is great not gonna do anything and
the hard workers were like even though I
worked hard I got nothing screw that I'm
not going to do any work and the grades
kept dropping so I'm saying we're
already there man
we're already there if you are listening
to this and you work in a warehouse and
you're driving you're a forklift
operator you're a truck driver you are
facing hardship you're facing lockdowns
you're you're a contractor you're a
carpenter you're whatever you're doing
physical labor every day and you know
your buying power is being diminished
because there are morbidly obese gen Z
and Millennials sitting in big cities
voting to take your money from you and
then going on Tick Tock and being like
our sugar have to have a job if this is
my problem with Medicare for all I don't
want to pay for people that are uh
intentionally or self-inflicting damage
on themselves either through eating
sugar that was my big one and Jimmy Dore
we had on the show one of the biggest
proponents of Medicare for all that I
know and I said that to him I don't want
it and he's like well what about people
that go skiing and break their leg like
is that self-inflicted good argument
Jimmy and but then I was like but
another big problem I have is that
people that make the medicine make the
sugar it's the same industry I can't I
don't have the paperwork to show it but
I know that the Pharma food industry is
is connected and they're very happy to
sell you sugar and then sell you the
medicine to heal the cancer later so I
don't want to medicate I don't want
Medicare I don't want to pay for
people's lazy or ignorance and I even
Jimmy was like that's a good point he
didn't have an answer for that so I
don't like Medicare for all and not not
on the straight up like let's pay for
everyone's in inconsistencies no this is
hilarious so I got this coke right here
that I'm drinking and it's like the
glass bottle pure sugar one and it says
it's got 39 added sugars which is 78 of
your daily sugar intake dear God that is
a lot of sugar based on a 2 000 calorie
diet yeah based on like probably 10
times more sugar than you're actually
supposed to have so you're probably
getting 700 of your daily sugar in that
yeah that's a guess but like you're
probably getting more than what the
number on the bottle is actually so
you're not supposed to eat refined sugar
it's crazy I'm just so powerful okay I'm
just gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pull the
audience on this one and just ask you
guys and everybody here do you think we
like young people need hard work right
now yeah and I actually think that one
of the best things that that older
Generations can do is to pull young
people into some sort of religious or
general Community I feel like I I watch
it time and time again I'm gen Z I'm 25
years old my generation's completely
lost on religion and you have to see the
these study after studies show that
people are depressed and yet the
religion is ticking down your true
Freedom does not come from being able to
sleep with whoever you want to sleep
with your true Freedom comes from peace
and peace comes from hard work
if you have none of that where are you
going to end up sad depressed fat on
Tick Tock and I think that the best
thing you can do is if you're that steel
worker that goes to church every Sunday
invite your fat Millennial okay like
invite them to church because to me
that's where the community gets built
and that's where people get happy and
feel free I think a part of the reason
why people don't want to work hard
anymore is also a result of the eroding
results that come from it and I'm
directly citing like Columbia University
is no longer requiring sat or ACT scores
in undergraduate admissions so like why
is anybody motivated to work hard and
try to do well in admissions anymore
people need to be cynical nowadays and
that's a way to get ahead you need to
cynically wield your identity when
applying to Columbia University you need
to write some BS in your college essay
and you're more likely to get in than if
you work hard on your sat or act so I
think you see you see that Delta I think
it was United Airlines they announced
the All lgbtq crew yeah yeah they were
like this is The Pride plane and the
crew is all lgbtq and I'm just like so
did like HR ask all of the applicants
about their sexual
you know proclivities like imagine
you're like I'm a pilot I would like
this job and they go okay and um how
many flight hours do you have oh yeah
that's that's a lot and do you sleep
with men or women and then the Pilot's
like uh man like oh so you're gay okay
we'll put that down well we have a great
opportunity for you they asked for
volunteers they're like look this is
what we want to do if there are any
members of the LGBT community that work
for Delta please blah blah blah this is
what our plan is it's simple it's
garbage yeah it's not even June but
here's my point as we move towards
automation one thing that Andrew Yang
didn't quite capture is that if there
are no skill based requirements for a
job because the AI is doing it then it's
going to be identity based requirements
for the job if anybody can press the
button then they're going to go for the
you know disabled trans person of color
whatever and be like well I mean look if
you're if you're a company like in
California they have board requirements
now or something like that I'm pretty
sure that they passed a law and they're
like your board has to have X many
people of color and females so they're
going to be like can we get all of that
in one person
and so if they got to hire somebody but
anyway look as as more things become
automated you're gonna have someone at a
McDonald's and their job is going to be
to watch the machines and if they break
to then call someone
well that if there's no qualification
it's going to be identity you go to
Walmart and it's all self-checkouts
basically which is really annoying and
they got one person just standing there
there's no real qualifications for the
job other than you have to be there well
then it's going to be identity based
yeah if our institutions start to creep
more towards caring about Dei for
reasons to hire people then it will come
at the cost of people's Merit and actual
skill at the jobs not only are we seeing
the SATs and acts being disregarded but
also what law schools we're seeing them
be disregard the mcats are being
disregarded now as as well it's like
these are the things I want my doctors
to know I want my lawyer to be able to
do really well on the outside I want my
you know my doctors to be able to do the
have the best scores on the mcats I
don't care if you're a black Indian
Jewish or whatnot so well we did see
some good news today out of Texas A M
their system cut their diversity equity
and include statements for admission
which is the first country or first
University in the country to do away
with all that crap and I think it might
have been the New York Times some
workplace was was talking on and on
about how George Floyd inspired Dei and
now a couple years later all the Dei
jobs are dying that's all just a lie
yeah all manipulation they can screw
themselves into a little manipulation
first of all this is the first college
we're seeing so how would that be
accurate that the New York Times is
saying that when this is one of the
first colleges Across the Nation and
it's a pretty conservative College
relatively it turns out that Vanguard is
pulling out of ESG did you guys see it's
what's a third of the global capital is
that really yeah pull this up dude
there's like a two-week-old article 50
trillion dollars they're not playing
this game they're going economic well
you pull it up there's one like I wanna
like you would mentioned someone to
mentioned talking about like why kids
are depressed like human beings are
human beings this is Vanguard CEO this
is holes out of the Net Zero managers
initiative and affirms his fiduciary
duty to clients we should this is day
one
it's like a week and a half ago yeah
seriously this this is them being like
hey uh get what go broke we lost too
much money and uh now we have no choice
esg's done this is this is it this is it
the blood has been sucked out of the
body it's not done it's it's it's this
is good but the ESG is is pushed by
ideologically motivated people so that's
like saying that a religion is done okay
it's not done but this is an example
that this of capitalism not functioning
with Communism communism is not
profitable and the capital system won't
use it well I mean it's it's good that
people are recognizing that ESG is not
good for for for results for companies
and stuff like that and it is it is
communism and it's it's not particularly
it's not intended or or simply melded
with capitalism but if you look at China
then that's there's another that refutes
your argument there because China has a
at least a surface level communist
society and they have markets and that's
what China did China took you know China
took uh the the basics of Marxism you
know maoism is is Marxist leninism with
Chinese characteristics and all they've
done is managed to implement markets but
they still have the control and they
still use the ideology of Communism to
to control the opinions of the
population because America we kind of
get this General sense that everyone in
China is feels like they're oppressed
and stuff and I don't think that that's
the case I don't think a billion and a
half people all hate their government
and are just waiting for the second to
rise up it's way more complex than that
so
good yeah I don't know how profitable
Chinese companies are realistically like
real profit like profit doesn't matter
in modern monetary Theory bro they they
are they are printing money and the
system has become so big the Petro
dollars become so big they know that
it's almost impossible to shake the
confidence in the value of the dollar so
they can just Mass print the money and
spend it wherever they want without a
thought no no they I mean not really
Thomas Massey actually was just talking
about this the last five trillion that
was printed was actually just created
out of thin air normally it's right they
always do that no normally they loan it
out you get Thomas Massey's brilliant
man
um and he pointed out that we actually
just diluted our economy I thought it
was always just printed out of thin air
but apparently it's been on the books
and then we're allowed to get it loan to
us so we know ahead of time how much is
going to be there the money the money
supply has expanded when a bank issues a
loan and now this last time they just it
is created it is created it is not when
a bank is issuing a loan the money is
fabricated in that moment yeah they then
just put in your account the loan the
money exists congratulations so I would
push back that I think modern monetary
theory is profitable and that's why it
worked and that what they're doing now
isn't modern monetary Theory you're
supposed to take out a huge loan
invested in infrastructure that you make
more than what you took out and you pay
back the loan that's modern monetary
Theory I don't think that that's
accurate well that's the idea is that's
what they did after World War II that's
not modern monetary Theory modern
monetary theory is is based on the idea
that because the the issuing country
requires that the people of the country
pay taxes in the the currency that was
issued that means that the currency is
always going to have value because you
have to pay taxes with that currency are
you sure there's no uh like premise of
building infrastructure with the loan
building that's policy that's not
monetary policy that's that's
infrastructure policy different things
they have created demand for the
currency by force if you do not pay what
you owe we will lock you up therefore
people are always going I need dollars
and as long as someone needs the dollars
the economy will keep on churning but
this also means it's a component of it
taxes aren't being paid uh so that we
can go to war like Ukraine the war in
Ukraine is not tax dollars they
fabricate this money and it extracts the
buying power from your bank account so
you're you're you're 500 bucks and your
bank doesn't move at all didn't change
but what you can buy with 500 bucks does
yeah and if you sit if today I was
talking about this a year ago with the
with the covid uh uh stimulus and all
that stuff I put a tablet in my Amazon
cart and then forgot to buy it and then
like a day later opened up Amazon and it
said alert prices have changed and it
went up like 130 bucks and I was like
whoa if I bought that like a week ago I
would have saved a lot of money almost
every time I order something on Amazon
that I've ordered in the past I'll check
my old order invoice to look at the old
price versus what I'm about to pay
because I'm fascinated with the changes
in price I'll see like a 10 change here
and there I mean inflation's a real
thing that like that's what Tim's
talking about but that when it comes to
like Taxation and stuff the the tax ju
to control inflation so like when you
say you know you when people talk about
paying taxes to pay bills they don't pay
taxes to you don't pay taxes to pay
bills the whole point of you paying
taxes is so that way there's less
currency moving through the system it's
literally taking money from you
specifically so you have less money is
that why taxes started up or was that if
they wanted to do that the FED could
just increase their rates no no that's
not that's the FED increases the
interest rates that's that's the cost of
borrowing money the taxation is what you
is what you have to pay to the federal
government to control inflation yeah and
that's like Tim said it controls
inflation they suck up the money and
they think government uses taxes as a
tool to control inflation I don't just
think yes I understand that's a fact
actually that's how that is that is
literally that's modern monetary that is
modern monitors I mean they're supposed
to so it's late but they might be using
it I don't know the US government can
create money if they want to
quantitative easing through the fed or
Barack Obama issue that stimulus or as
Ian pointed out the last five trillion
was just fabricated the purpose of
paying taxes is not so that money can be
used for war technically you can say it
is but it's to control for inflation
because the government can manifest
money wherever they want but if they do
too much you'll get runaway inflation so
they need to then bring down the money
supply inverse but like on the state and
local level they're collecting of course
to help pay for that's because they're
not property taxes the federal federal
taxes okay yeah because State and State
and local state and localities don't
issue the currency yeah I just thought
that the most effective tool to control
inflation though would be feds changing
the rates and influencing the money if
they combine it if the U.S government is
through various means or the economy is
expanding the money supply
and there's no controls for that you can
run away inflation you look at these
countries where they just Mass print
money they get trillion dollar bills and
then also it's worthless overnight
because it's hyperinflation so you need
a way to restrict the money supply to
make sure things don't get out of
control so the system doesn't break
you'll find there's the autonomous
massive video I'm referencing is where
he pours water into the iced tea to
explain dilution of the economy and
everyone's like I mean I don't know what
they're doing but he's like explaining
to like third graders it's really
awesome so if you type Thomas Massey
iced tea you might find it on the
internet so like with Nordic countries
they have super high tax rates that's
um they're trying to control and okay
they they can't issue Petro dollars so
for some of these countries it probably
is true but the U.S is the global
Reserve currency so we can just
fabricate money we don't need to and
manufacture apparently according to
Massey uh all the countries of Earth as
well inflated the crap out of their
economy when we printed that five
trillion and that's the only reason or
the main reason why we haven't gone
under yes because everyone's we print
out a ton of money but China prints out
even more and it's interesting how their
economy works but Chrissy do you have
any thoughts on all this money talk I am
learning so much right now can I just
say that I'm like this is over my head
in terms of like my everyday thing and
I'm fascinated because I'm just learning
so much don't you love being the
stupidest person in the room oh hell
yeah it's the best
well you know we're all really dumb and
just talking about our assets I don't
know it feels right I might have to fact
check everything later yeah I thought it
was about the money supply and the FED
but hey I'm willing to be real I've
never had it I've never had a thought of
my own I only repeat things that I've
heard so I'm not smart wait a minute but
I only learned this from you
philosophy
you can actually Google modern monetary
Theory and and oh you can Bing it if you
feel dirty hey be careful they might
have changed the definition though I
thought that it was about investing in
infrastructure but are you that that's
policy modern monetary theory is the is
the the
the policy that the government has
regarding the monetary uh the monetary
policy the policy you're talking about
is like infrastructure policy so like
they would they would take loans or or
create money so that way they could pay
people that are going to build buildings
or whatever like the new deal yeah
that's that's that's stimulating the
economy that's different than creating
the money that goes into the economy you
know what I mean like the monetary
policy that they have is is different
than like an infrastructure policy
they're different things wasn't there
like a trillion dollars missing from
like the pentagon's books or something
it happens a lot apparently yeah my
conspiracy on that is that we're making
a special little something okay that
that's too much money to just go missing
September 10th but right before 9 11 but
it might not be like one chunk of two
two trillion it might just be accounting
errors yeah
accounting errors can be scary I'll tell
you that because if somebody cross you
know carries a one in the wrong place
then all of a sudden your tax preparer
comes to you and says you know oh you
actually owe seven thousand more dollars
and you're like how is that possible
like I'm overpaid and they go oh I
carried a one in the wrong spot it
looked like you had more money than you
did and I'm like thank you that's you
know that's that's crazy so when it
comes to the auditing problems with the
Pentagon and the Federal Reserve we need
to audit them here it is Donald Rumsfeld
in 2001 announced that the Pentagon had
lost the Department of Defense had lost
more than 2.3 trillion dollars lost lost
but hold on hold on what's your Source
what's your Source this is a video from
how money works
I mean I've heard this story for two
decades yeah the story I heard was they
could not account for 2.3
that that means the money is just not
tracked properly it could still be in
their Bank it could have been spent
somewhere but someone you know gave a
hundred thousand dollars from to one
department and then didn't write it down
and so they're like where did that money
go I don't remember but it's still there
yes from Armstrong economics says the
office of the inspector General's
reported that department offense is
missing 6.5 trillion up from 2.3
trillion this is due to an increase in
government spending under the Obama
Administration from 2.9 to 3.5
that's uh insane so they're missing 6.5
trillion
I mean that's that's absolutely
scandalous that the government has gone
Rogue I don't know what to do uh Thomas
Jefferson's It's So Scandalous no one
even cares
let's talk about uh some cultural stuff
real quick yes please well we had this
story from the post-millennial daily
wires Jeremy boring launches new
Chocolate Company in response to
Hershey's woke trans stunt they did this
so fast I am impressed I will play for
you the video right that's because
they're just re-wrapping chocolate that
exists well but that's all chocolate is
you
like all these everyone's got a coffee
company yeah like I did not buy a coffee
roaster and then you know I think I
think the quarter Jeremy according
literally did oh really yeah what we did
was we found a provider we we talked to
them about the blend that we wanted and
the kind of coffee that we like and
they're they're creating for us a
specific thing and then we put our label
on it because it's our version of a
coffee they so they'll make a bunch
different kinds of coffee what we're
doing is combining the ones we like and
then selling it under our name
but here's here's the commercial for you
guys International women's day is a I
got it hold on there we go upon us again
and I love an international woman but
our friends over at Hershey's they don't
even know what a woman is they've hired
a biological male to be the spokesperson
for their women's day campaign and
they're calling that campaign and I
swear I'm not making this up her she
Hershey it's humiliating and it's the
reason I'm watching
Jeremy's chocolate we have two kinds
she her
and he him
one of them's got nuts if you need me to
tell you which one it is keep giving
your money Bill Michael is laughing
tired of getting your money to whoa
corporations that hate you and you're
looking for a delicious chocolate bar
from a company that actually wants your
business head over to ihatehersheys.com
and Order Jeremy's chocolate today I I
I'm sorry man the daily wire does
awesome stuff that this is brilliant uh
I I said when the whole uh Hershey
women's day trans thing happened I was
like you shouldn't boycott Hershey
because they hired a trans person okay
you should not do that you should
boycott Hershey because it's disgusting
garbage sugar that kills you and you
should eat an avocado or something I
thought you were going to get Ginger
joke about the trans person yeah if it
doesn't say I don't know they're
probably using slave labor to acquire
the cacao if it doesn't say fair trade
on the past would you what if what if
the daily wire chocolate is like the
most brutal dictator oh Jeremy get fair
trade bro I'll buy it if it's fair trade
I want it more now if not I gotta say
Brett Cooper held it down in that video
she's awesome I think as an actor she's
gonna be like a superstar in the world
and it's just now building up the
comment section but she came she was a
child actor in Hollywood and they hired
her so when you go to I hate Hershey's
it actually brings you to
jeremy'srazers.com
and uh and then you can buy Jeremy's
chocolate binary
brilliant nuts nuts and nutless and uh
I'll tell you what they did
they probably as soon as this happened
they had someone design she or him
they probably bought a chocolate bar
from Walgreens or whatever supermarkets
they have in in Nashville and then just
printed out the paper wrapped it around
the thing for a prop then they went they
called the bespoke chocolate labeler and
they said we want to sell the chocolate
and they said we can have it packaged
for you because when you go to Hershey
Park
you can actually get your own bar made
like there's this thing where you walk
into this room and then you pick what
you want like I want white chocolate
with toffee bits and then I want it
covered in dark chocolate Hershey
Pennsylvania
yeah yeah I went to that factory once
yeah we we went there a little while ago
I won't go there now but uh they make a
box and everything and the funny thing
is when I went there they do this thing
where they take the first three letters
of your last name
and then put it on your bar so when I
got my chocolate with nuts and it was
lumpy and brown it had the first three
letters of my last name on the box and
so I went to the the woman who was
running I said ma'am can I can I get a
different label for this box and she was
a young man first and he goes no you
can't and I was like my guy I am not
going to spend was like 50 bucks on a
poo bar
You Got It You Gotta Give me a better
box for this if you told me they would
do that I would not have put my last
name on The Box
and so then the lady came over and
looked at it and started laughing and I
was like I was kind of perturbed that
they told me no you're the poo bar
and so when the lady came back and
started laughing at first I was a little
irked but I started laughing too and I
was like it's amazing isn't it and then
she took it and she gave me a new box
but they they like there's a machine
that does it all so I didn't get the
properly sealed box like everybody else
got because mine said poo on it they had
to give me a stock box and then just
drop it in there and then tape it shut
and I'm like you know this is you can't
win but that that anyway some people got
a rough anyway story aside uh you you
should like
I I'll probably end up I think I'm gonna
buy a crapload of this stuff I think I'm
gonna buy like 500 bars and I'm gonna
have them downstairs for guests and for
employees and it's going to be funny
because you're gonna walk in and and and
you know what's it actually says nuts
and nutless on them
I I love it I love Jeremy I love daily
wire but I don't want it a sugar that's
my only downside if it was a product
like a meatless meat yeah whatever look
the worst that's not what I mean the
worst thing about when I try to get that
Hershey bar is that I I put everything
in it
so like when I was what it is it's like
it's like a bowl it's a chocolate bar
with with a with an edge around it to
hold the stuff in and I was like I want
white chocolate chips I want chocolate
chips I want toffee bits so it created
this big Mound and then it blankets it
it wasn't called it in robes it in
chocolate
and so what comes out everyone else has
like this thin normal looking bar and
mine's lumpy and weird looking and then
they wrote poo on it and I was just like
I was like come on photo op I probably
should have just taken it like that's
right that's right we've got a big lumpy
chocolate I was like I would have put a
fake name if you told me you're gonna do
that was it good when you ate it yeah of
course it was it was it like too many
ingredients because Harkins back in the
day of when I had no money at Subway and
I'd be like extra everything and then
that would be my meal dude I'd go to
Wendy's and I would be like I would like
the uh the dollar menu Junior you know
cheeseburger deluxe or whatever and I
want quadruple extra tomato quadruple
extra lettuce and quadruple extra cheese
like whatever's free and then some
places the cheese like cheese is extra
but sometimes they would tell me they
didn't care and I'd be like how many
tomatoes can I get they were like I
don't know tomatoes are free and I was
like kind of get seven they'd be like I
guess and I'm like I need food and I'm
poor yes
this is your belly so there's a lot of
people who aren't like the biggest fans
of the daily wire that aren't the most
bullish on The Daily wire and I think
you know the chocolate bar is a little
bit gimmicky the he him the the nutless
though even though this great line it's
a little bit gimmicky but I think you
really do need to give the daily wire so
much credit because they do so many
different things across the board
between Matt Walsh's lobbying for
different
um bands against you know these
conversions these trans conversion
surgeries in Tennessee or signing Jordan
Peterson or Jeremy's razors or I know
they're also doing children's books and
Chrissy maybe you could tell me a little
bit of some of their other projects
going on but they're just really willing
to work on these other projects and I
think a lot of people in the right-wing
movement or conservative movement aren't
willing to put as many risks out
um like the daily wire seems to be doing
so I'm really bullish on them and I
think they're doing a great job and they
should continue doing stuff like this in
the space
I agree I'm a Daily Caller or a Daily
Caller yeah she's at a different company
were you previously a daily walk yeah
okay so previously yet I'm ordering two
thousand dollars worth of Jeremy's
chocolate right now do it I'm not I'm
not even what's the website I hate
hersheys.com yeah
and they're getting some orders tonight
yeah I'm ordering 480 bars how many how
many times how many hers it's half of H
is 250. I wonder if they made a trans
flavor like a half nut half knot I think
that's the whole or just a whole nut if
it's which yeah whole nut would be a
good well because no matter you can't
make it half and half either way right
there's no way to get to half an order
confirmed give me the nuts
in the trans man chocolate bar there's
just random things but they could they
could do they could do a bunch of stuff
that would be like funny to make fun of
you know why don't they do like trans
women and just send you a bag of nuts
that's well but no but they could do
like like I don't know they could
they're doing nuts and nut lists like
okay what else do you got you can make
uh like cookies and cream and then oh
yeah or you knew you could do one where
it's um white chocolate with uh I'm
sorry I'm sorry you know it's got to be
like banana cream with white chocolate
inside they can make like an
Americanized Asian joke or something you
know what I would really love is a white
and dark chocolate swirl bar if you can
pull that off they could they could make
like an American flag bar and they could
be like you know we don't need none of
this there you go we're Americans I mean
actually that's a really cool thing
today like strawberry in it or something
well imagine this imagine you like open
the wrapper and it's an American flag
but it's a candy bar and you got like
strawberry white chocolate and I guess
blueberries watch the food coloring
don't use that pharmaceutical uh tar
coal tar you know yellow five Lake and
crap like that or what is it
petroleum-based I have no idea no food
coloring yeah the yellow flies or
something but no I I I I no joke I just
ordered uh 20 I think I ordered 20 packs
nice so that's what is that 420 24 packs
480 it was two thousand dollars but uh
we were in a business here and um I'm
pretty sure that when we have guests
here when they go down and they it's not
about eating them it's about seeing it
okay and people are gonna be like that's
awesome so it's an important business
purchase dude
it's important to support daily because
you like their projects and if you think
what they're doing is cool then sporting
them is great who do you think fast they
did it in like six hours who do you
think came up with nutless let's take a
toll I think it was just dude okay hold
on I don't know the daily wire guys
we're sitting around and like I'm
imagining Jeremy smoking a cigar and
he's like we should make a chocolate bar
to like make fun of Hershey's and
someone's like oh dude we should call it
nutless and like that's a great idea
thing like Michael Knowles comes in and
they're high-fiving each other like do
it
I think Knowles came up with it he
doesn't get enough credit he's smart
smart guy Candace suggested Candace
Owens suggested I start a hair care line
and I was like damn when Candice Owens
tells you should start a company you
should probably start the company it's
kind of like Rogan telling you you
should do this start doing it why was
she complimenting your hair yeah she was
like you got great whatever she didn't
give me the accomplish she was just like
you should do that and I'm like yeah man
they they are set up now daily wire
where they have that whole system ready
to go if they want to start a business
they got the lawyers they got the
business contacts they'll like make it
happen and then they have a chocolate
company make it happen so it's like once
you get into that Echelon of friendship
or like compatriots then they're also
doing entertainment I think they're
trying to compete with Netflix too and
make their own shows I think they hired
somebody who got fired from Disney if
I'm not mistaken and tried to make a
movie with them um they're doing a ton
of projects good for them let's let's
jump to this story we got from CNBC and
it's you know both sad and funny at the
same time resumes including they them
pronouns are more likely to be
overlooked new report fines well gee I'm
not I'm I'm so shocked inclusivity
shouldn't just be present in the
workplace it should be practiced during
the hiring process but unfortunately
non-binary job Seekers are facing clear
biases biases during their job search
according to a new report from
business.com a business resource
platform over 80 percent of non-binary
people believe that identifying as
non-binary would hurt their job search
similarly 51 believe their gender
identity has affected their workplace
experience very or somewhat negatively
I gotta I gotta I gotta make a point if
you wrote down on your resume that you
were
that you identify as a globa dupe right
Global dupe
they're not going to hire you they're
gonna I don't I don't I don't know what
this is weird and they're going to say
they don't hire guava zoops here not not
my point is this no we do we do actually
but my point is if an employer looks at
a resume and they're like what the does
that mean they're not they're not going
to hire you can be like I have no idea
what this is I have to put it to the
back of the pile immediately yeah
they're gonna say look man look I don't
know what you're talking about at first
like is they them like what is this
non-binary is a made-up thing in the
past several years no one even
understands I know that gender and sex
are different and sexuality is different
than sex you can be male you can have a
sexuality that's I like guys or girls
but like this the reason that jobs don't
ask for your your sexual preference when
you're signing up because you don't want
to be discriminated against why don't
offer it like literally if you hire that
you are hiring a lawsuit you are hiring
an HR problem if you hire someone but do
these do these uh resumes go to a
separate pile that then get sent to HR
so when they're like I need a diversity
hire they got their stack right there uh
not if you're smart I'm not saying
saying it's a smart tactic I'm just
saying that's what they need to do to
diversity I mean maybe I think that you
can probably achieve diversity hires
without going for you could because the
thing is if you if you hire someone that
said has she her or he him pronouns
right you're you're probably going to
get a person that is just looking to go
to work and do their job and looking to
just live their life however they want
if you hire someone whose pronouns are
Zer Zim you're hiring someone that's
going to make your job a living hell
they're going to ruin your workplace
they're going to come in and they're
going to bring their ideal ideology
along with them and every business is
going to be like it is way easier to
avoid people that use Neo pronouns or
they them pronouns and just hire people
that use she and her and he and him you
may end up with trans people and that's
fine because they're just normal trans
people that are just looking to live
their lives not politically queer people
that are activists that are looking to
ruin your company that's a good point I
think in general that that's probably
true there probably I'm sure instances
where someone would have zizer and
they're totally cool but I think when
you've got to make huge decisions about
thousands of people you don't have time
to go person by person you've got to
make you know Split Second decisions and
stuff are people really putting their
pronouns like this is a normal thing
because I'm looking at templates right
now and even like the big websites
aren't saying that you should be putting
your pronouns in your this is probably
not liar and that's the reason it got
such attention because it's like yo I
have one word of business advice for
people and this key to know your
audience so the only place where
pronouns in your resume might help is I
don't know Media Matters or the ACLU or
CNN but if you're applying somewhere
else then it probably wouldn't be the
best idea you always have to tailor your
resume a little bit to the job you want
so if it is a leftist organization they
probably would like that they them or
the pronouns in the resume but otherwise
probably your best bet to not put it in
here's here's the issue it may be that
very few people are actually putting
they them in their in their resumes and
the media looking for some issue decides
to write about this Fringe group of
people that aren't that numerous here's
an example this is great Christopher
rufo tweeted it's a sign of immense
progress that in a search for racism
Publications like the New York Times
have to invent increasingly Niche and
implausible incidents of supposed
bigotry such as woman with large
dreadlocks has trouble finding
equestrian helmet the New York Times
written an article it says black
equestrians want to be safe but they
can't find helmets for Black Riders with
natural hair finding a helmet that fits
can be virtually impossible some are
trying to raise awareness for the
problem but manufacturers say it's not a
simple fix I love this because he was
like quote I'm having trouble finding a
horse riding helmet it's racism bro it's
like a white dude with dreadlocks too
so that like this is kind of the point
the media is like we found a person who
has chosen to have long hair and not a
helmet won't fit racism
that's the thing like CNBC writing about
non-binary people is just trying to
create some kind of Injustice narrative
to get collection I get disability you
know build me a ramp so that I can get
into the front of the building I get
that but when it comes to like Dre my
head doesn't fit in your helmet you
don't force someone to build you a
helmet that's totalitarianism you build
your own Helmet or yeah you start a
company and hire people to help you make
it you go to a helmet maker and be like
I would like a helmet that can fit my
dreads and they're going to be like bro
your hair's too big the helmet's got to
be snug and protect your brain
oh you show up at a place you say look
the helmet doesn't fit it's racism now I
get to be in charge that's literally
what they're doing it's a good idea
that's exactly what that's what that's
what critical theories are all stuff
races until you control it James Lindsay
right there new study that like 93 of
kids in this in America can now
demonstrate or understand at least one
tenet of critical race Theory like if
you thought about critical race Theory
five years ago thinking that it would
have a 93 success rate that's unreal I
question that that number though where
did you get is that like a poll or
something yeah it was like a thousand
people pulled yeah it's difficult to pin
down a tenant of critical race Theory
because it becomes this kind of
amorphous idea but I I understand more
but it's hard to learn talking about
school kids right these are kids that
are still in like uh K-12 yeah so I mean
the fact that these kids can identify
one of the Core Concepts of whatever
they'll call it social emotional
learning critical race Theory you know
their problematic tenants to be teaching
kids they know that it's critical race
Theory no no of course it doesn't matter
what it's called the because when you
start when you start when you start
labeling it the first thing that happens
is that is people that are pro whatever
it is they start telling you no we don't
they don't teach that they start lying
they'll change the definitions yes
they'll just lie to you so they're being
indoctrinated yeah yeah they're totally
being inducted 100 indoctrination it is
a cult basically yeah like communism is
a cult the whole the whole kitten
caboodle well like here's here's an
example actually because I just tweeted
something out I uh I saw a tweet from
the krakensteins for those aren't
familiar they're like prominent liberals
and Brian said dear Republicans if you
think drag queens reading books about
love and inclusion to your kids is bad
you might want to check out some of the
verses from the Bible that your local
priest is reading to them so I responded
with okay now try a non-theist adult sex
performers should not be around kids and
he said 100 I'm not aware of any sexual
performances that book readings are you
and uh there actually are they're just
first and foremost drag is an adult sex
performance yes and they're lying to you
they are lying to you and I'll say it
again they are lying to you when you had
these child drag queens ripping their
clothes off on stage for adult gay men
handing the money they said it's just a
costume change it's just a cast and I'm
like right when the go-go dancer in
states that have banned full nude
stripping are dancing on the pole and
then rip off their top and they're
wearing a bra it's just a costume change
no it's a sexualized adult performance
it's meant to titillate so when you when
you when you put a go-go dancer or a
stripper in a book club we would call
that an adult sex performer reading two
children
and they should they we shouldn't we
shouldn't do that and everybody replying
to that that's saying it's not
sexualized you're all lying garbage
people well they're just the worst evil
pieces of garbage there is why is it
always that it's we know it's sexualized
when it's straight but we don't know
it's sexualized or it becomes mumbled
when it's because
like LGBT it's it doesn't make any sense
why is it all of a sudden not sexualized
because we're pushing a specific
ideological agenda because all communist
lies I think a lot of it is hold on
Blair white tweeted taking kids to a
drag show to teach them to respect gay
people is the equivalent of taking them
to a strip club to respect women yeah
is it Blair white being an influencer
it's not
as bad obviously as drag queen's Story
Hour but aren't you normalizing the idea
of trans people almost as much if you
have a transition Blair white Blair
white has every right to be on the
internet I'm not saying YouTube videos
and she doesn't but she realizes the
idea oh well some people would say
normalizing the eye the idea of being a
successful transgender person and being
conformed in that new identity is wrong
to teach children that because it could
lead them to think that no we don't
think that meant to happen but that's a
totally different circumstance Blair
white being on the internet talking
about
you know being Blair white being an
infiltr having ideas is not the same as
showing up in a g string to a children's
reading hour or whatever or to a bar
telling the kids it's not going to lick
itself and then spreading your legs and
thrusting your hips in front of
someone's face Blair's very reasonable
she'll tell you like I'm a man and I'm a
trans woman and she can be both at the
same time in fact you have to be you
never stop being a man when you
transition to trans woman you never stop
it's you can be both at the same time
that's very important I guess the idea
becomes do you think she helps normalize
the idea the trend people can transition
successfully I actually just did an
interview with a mom who was she's a a
lifelong Democrat like blue dog Democrat
still lives in California and her
daughter underwent a phase when she
thought she was transgender grew up like
typical young girl like had like eight
dresses around her always wearing
dresses very cute very friendly
um and then went on to identify as a man
for about a year and a half and that was
a concern that that Mom raised um so I
don't think it's what specifically that
she said I you know I think my daughter
watched a lot of Blair white and that
this is what she she called us now do I
think that I'm not opining I'm just
saying that was a con that was a valid
concern of a mother who you know whose
daughter underwent all of this there is
an argument if if there is an argument
to be made surrounding this particular
issue about Blair white or trans people
that's an issue for parents to deal with
agree that's something for parents to
deal with with their children and
parents to act like children to raise
their children Blair white has every
right to get on it on YouTube and make
videos if she wants absolutely and to
even even discuss it in a way as if it's
somehow you know the onus is on Blair to
not do that is in my opinion absolutely
outside of of the bounds of and now
reasonable conversation what is not
reasonable for YouTube is when they had
these videos a while ago they got in
trouble for this it was adults showing
children adult toys and things like that
and there was a backlash they're like
we're doing sex ed for kids like that is
not something YouTube should be
recommending to kids and now they're
doing the same same thing lgbtq content
is sex ed content yes and it is it is
something the parents have to discuss
and we've talked about this as much as
they'll all try to lie about the
opinions of people on this show my
attitude's always been like if a parent
decides the appropriate age for their
child to start learning about these
things about different marriages about
gay straight sexual reproduction and
things like that the parents need to
figure that stuff out there's a
difference between a parent being like
son I want to teach you about the birds
and the bees and these schools giving
kids pornography and like mentally
traumatizing content and bringing in
adult sex performers that's all way over
the line did you see that little kid in
I believe it was Maine who was uh he
went in front of his school board and
read a pornographic book and was like I
found this in my library it's allegedly
for kids over the age of 13. I'm 11 but
I'm in the same school as 13 year olds
so I have access to it his name's like
zayad or something interesting clip
anyway where was it let's can we find it
yeah for sure let me see if I can
I forget what his name was but it was a
main kid reads pornography to school
board Maybe
I was thinking oh yeah it is Knox zadac
thank you three days ago from NY New
York Post
this is right here yeah this kid 11 year
old sixth grader it is Graphics sexually
explicit book Nick and Charlie in front
of the school board in Maine the book
was on display at the his Middle School
library these are the books being
offered to kids in public schools and
that's this is this is the problem
I have no issue with a person who uh I'm
not a conservative sorry I'm just not if
like a lot of conservatives take issue
with Dave Rubin he's a gay married man
he had two kids through surrogacy you
know Libby Evans was on the show
frequently is very critical of surrogacy
and my attitude is kind of like uh I'm
not I'm fairly Neutron so I can say I
don't know enough about it I don't
really have a strong opinion I think
Dave will be one of the better parents
that this country will ever see I think
him and his husband are going to raise
two of the most well-functioning human
beings this country will will probably
get because Dave is an extremely high
functioning and intelligent individual
who will do a good job and I don't I
don't I I'm not gonna make that
traditional argument it's not me but
they will lie the left will lie and try
and lump all of us in the same category
and say that we're transphobic we're
homophobic and it's like dude I we we've
had multiple trans people on the show
The only weapon they have to defend
pedophilia is to lie and accuse us of
hating all LGBT people because we
specifically call out grooming children
everything from the left is everything
that's a moralized argument is almost
always them lying about someone else
it's not like you're you very rarely
hear the the people that are accusing
are you very very rarely hear people
that have been accused of being
anti-trans or being uh homophobic or
whatever you you don't hear them on
these horrible Triads like the Richard
Spencer raging against the Jews like you
don't hear that and so they have to make
stuff up because people generally aren't
really repulsed by trans people most
people are just like look do your thing
live your life the way you want to live
it I'll live mine it'll be it's the
behavior yeah like when that individual
went to the Game Stop and it was
screaming and smacking things like that
aggressive behavior could come from
anybody if it was a woman they'd call it
they call her a Karen well should we
play this video is it is it really
graphic uh
there's one F-bomb I will warn you now I
don't mind that just letting everybody
know yeah showing pictures or anything
no no pictures no all right just just a
warning if you have kids in the room or
something
I was in the library and this book was
on a stand I'd like to read you a page
my back over my hips as I ask if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling it especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible it
looks great I didn't know what we were
doing but it was good too so good
because we were a mess of emotions and
we were scared and excited and
everything felt new so this sort of
thing just sort of feels like that Nick
touches me like he's scared that in a
minute
what book was that
Nick and Charlie it's like about it's
like two it's it's about gay people or
something
two teen board boys stealing wine from
their parents and proceeding to
experiment sexually with one another
guys he can't even say library properly
like why should he be learning about he
says libraries I want to thank you Knox
for speaking up and out you got courage
man yeah nice job
that's that's a brutal to have to go
through that dude and I think the dad
said that this is actually not just at
the younger kids school he has an older
son who was at um a high school in the
area and said the book genderqueer is
allowed oh I have it yeah it's here yeah
sorry to interrupt you were saying no no
exactly but that's available in their
high school so it's clearly just that's
nuts because it's inside putting up like
penises oh I mean I've seen the penises
but you gotta read it crazy that that
what he read man that that was not in
school when I was in school we had like
Newberry uh Amelia Bedelia and all this
stuff
yeah I wasn't in school that long ago
like I feel like how has it changed that
much it would have been a huge deal if
someone found that book in my school oh
yeah everyone would have known about it
it would have been all our parents I
would have told her my parents everybody
would have known about it it would have
been a just uh people would have lost
their jobs for this kind of thing in
1987. the genderqueer book I think most
people watching the show already know
what I've had to say about it but
conservatives haven't even read it and
every time I talk to some conservatives
like oh yeah I know that book I'm like
did you read it the answer is no and
then my attitude is like this is why I
am not in favor of blanket book bands
because people should be able to have
access to something to understand what
it is
that's totally different than if
children are getting access to something
I think certain you know information
like certain books and stuff should be
restricted for children obviously we ban
porn but this book is the story of the
extreme psychological abuse of a young
woman and how it created someone who is
traumatized and needs like deep therapy
it is not this it is not so uh for a few
examples for those who didn't hear this
she couldn't read till she was 12. she
was pissing outside when she was a child
she was never taught how to take care of
her body so she would wear old crusted
pads in school and she smelled like
feces to the point where she got called
into the counselor and they complained
and said people are complaining of your
smell and you need to do something about
this so this poor young woman Harry lags
hairy armpits
totally unsocialized by weird hippie
parents whoever ping in the yard and
then she she feels she feels some kind
of social rejection because she doesn't
know how to fit in with her peers and
she writes about it how she's like I
can't read I smell bad and people are
being mean to me so so she she she's not
she's not non-binary she's just
traumatized because she was not because
her parents abused her and this this
thing book that Knox is reading I still
don't know Nick and Charlie uh about two
young underage kids drinking alcohol
like is that a form of neglect abuse by
the parents think it's not that you
can't like a kid's gonna do what a kid
does but I believe if you parent the kid
properly like I didn't drink until I was
23 because my parents told me don't do
it it's horrible for you I tasted it
once it tasted disgusting I was like all
right I'm not gonna do it I think you
might be in the minority on that yeah
that's kind of weird I gotta say it's
kind of weird that um this Nick and
Charlie book's written by a woman
I just think that's weird maybe that's
just me
like if it was written by a gay man
writing about his experience growing up
and discovering he was getting stuff I'd
be like I get it but it's written by a
woman who is like it almost seems like
some kind of weird
I don't know she's sitting there
imagining what it must be like to be a
teenage boy hooking up with another
teenage boy it just it's just doesn't
you think that their mentality because
this should not be in a school a book
about two young underage kids having sex
with each other should not be in a
government School in my opinion but you
think the argument's like hey there's so
many books anyway we can't keep count
and it's all on the internet anyway if
they want to read it it's there I've
heard that argument a lot of times like
if kids want to get access to the stuff
they're going to get access to it so we
might as well have it be like the uh you
know Pulitzer prize-winning version of
it access to information because of the
internet is a big issue I think when an
age where kids could get on the internet
could be a big issue because if they
could access the internet they could get
crazier stuff than anything that's
written in this book absolutely I don't
know what about tick tocks like this the
woman who wrote this she's like 28 or 29
years old yeah so we see videos of tick
tock of crazier stuff people are going
to drag queen story hours and there have
been some crazy videos that they
uploaded recently of some things in
England where they're like tripping in
front of maybe so that's like doing
secretary's performance moves in front
of babies I'm not even exaggerating it's
like a dozen babies all crawling on the
ground and they're like remember when we
saw that for like the Teletubbies when
you were like oh my gosh the Teletubbies
and now it's like oh my gosh a stripper
for babies I think the Teletubbies were
grooming kids because that was after my
kid time I was out of the house I just
thought they were so weird and
brainwashy like
after and like making this weird beeping
sounds and like gyrating back and I'm
like what is this God it was weird I
don't know I was mesmerized
scariest thing was no it was the Flaming
baby head burning baby head that would
be in the sky going and you're like no
Teletubbies was fine I don't know I just
don't understand why I do all this weird
stuff for kids where it's like think
about the pre-television era what were
children seeing all day every day in
their entertainment a human being
telling a story reading a book with very
few pictures and then when TV comes
around all of a sudden you got like
Snuffleupagus and like big bird and
weird creepy monster things going like
oh well and the kids are like I identify
with that
there was a time we got furries um yes
parents put kids in front of TVs and
turn on Looney Tunes and then these kids
start identifying with the social
interactions of cartoon animals and
that's why when you look at pictures of
furries they don't dress up like actual
animals they dress up like Bugs Bunny
kind of animals with big eyes and they
look like cartoon characters one of the
anime culture too though furry yeah I
don't know about that oh my gosh yeah
these I mean we were just at um katsukan
um my team and I well I didn't go but my
team went and we were all discussing
everything it's fascinating to see the
anime culture and a the road inroads it
has into grooming actually what is
katsukan I'm sorry it's
version of like anime lover nerdy people
it's it's I it felt very harmless when I
was there until I learned how the
inroads of it I mean that that can take
you from
something very harmless like dressing up
like a furry or dressing up like an
animal furry is not cosplay
yes and yes and no some of them have
those conventions just like that I mean
they're not the same thing
furry is very different from cosplay but
there's probably some overlap for sure
yeah some furries cosplay some don't
yeah there was a cosplaying furry at my
high school yeah I mean there's there's
for some reason furry Nazis like they
wear ferk suits and they get like they
dress up like a guy whatever man I don't
know I was fortunate to grow up in the
era of Reading Rainbow with LeVar Burton
what's up Levar one of the best I mean
just
easy shows where he just reads a book or
actually a kid would read the book and
then Mr Rogers where it's a guy a
genuine dude like sitting there looking
at the camera giving you encouragement
and then educating You by reading you
books and telling you about it's how to
tie your shoes and like things you know
like things that kids may not know I I
thought
I thought that
type it out it wasn't it wasn't it's not
a typable thing but like until you're
able as a human to create order in in
reality around you I don't think you
should have the ability to cut yourself
up or or sterilize yourself and like I
just assumed every kid eventually will
get to a place where they can create
order in reality I don't think that's
the case though no you need a good
strong parental unit to help you learn
how to do that I think we're seeing how
broken culture and Society is because of
the the us being cut from our roots you
know what is it cut flower politics or
whatever that uh Dennis Prager calls it
you pluck the flower from its roots and
it looks beautiful but then eventually
Withers and decays and so we've been
severed from the roots that have made
this country an amazing place and so now
we're starting to wither you know I
would like to do Tim cash show if you
want to do a show where I read books to
kids and talk to them and encourage them
I think that's we need more of that it
doesn't have to be the kids I actually
have I did the Phantom toll booth I have
like a 19 video series on YouTube on my
playlists where I read the Phantom toll
booth it's one of my most popular it's
my most popular playlist by far no we
should do a go-go dancer Story Hour yeah
we need more awesome like just genuine
encouragement for children the left
would love it you make tons of money
they're totally into that stuff right
that's a money maker right there go go
dancer Story Hour there's no difference
there's literally none go-go dancers do
not get naked they dance on stage they
shut around for tips and they remove
parts of clothing but they still keep
their undergarments is it just too like
is it just have we evolved past showing
kids puppets and telling them you're
okay and and being cool is that just no
more no give it up like forget about it
move on I hear a point actually just
goes to my point that I made earlier
which is like the go-go dancers would
somehow be dubbed inappropriate because
you're sexualizing women because it's a
straight thing but you know you get into
you make it LGBT male go go dancers
I don't even know you're not explaining
only if the male's kiss you
each other there you go
it's not really in a pro then it's
considered appropriate like I don't even
want to wait wait I don't even want to
read other people
but they kissed before
then it would be appropriate like the
society the reaction I just got from
mentioning talking and reading to kids
is like it's like this don't mess with
other people's kids like I don't even
want to get involved now I don't even
want to touch it like let those kids do
it on their own I don't want to have
somebody who said this oh the whole the
whole vibe is like it's just so dirty
about like Ian's feelings got hurt
because nobody supported it I don't know
man why are people not more interested
in helping children I don't they will
talk about the problems all day no but
where's the solutions I don't think
anybody had a negative view of you doing
a story hour like we're like Ian's kids
show you don't get it you know I like
you if you want to be a story hour go to
a public library I'm sure if you
advertised it people would love to show
up you have a lot of insightful things
just don't talk about drugs in front of
the kids
Batman's gonna be like sitting in a
chair and be like all right this book's
called Pinocchio and it kind of reminds
me the time I did DMT you kids ever do
DMT no what's DMT oh let me tell you all
about it one day when you're an adult
you're gonna do a bunch of psychedelics
that's a good cast Castle bit actually
oh okay let's do for cast Castle
it would be funny if you tried to look
like a drag because I mean you already
have long hair and then you did a
drugstore dude I did I was in Hamlet in
college and I was played Liberties uh
and I was getting ready for the show and
putting makeup I was like I would make a
hot chick looking at my jawline I look
good I had long hair I was back in a
ponytail you should if you convert it to
trans maybe you'd be able to do it what
is it transition played women on stage
before
uh one woman in one show it was awesome
I think there's a picture of it out
there anyway man I feel like uh
I think part of the issue is there is
some truth to the social component
socialization that the left is making
the argument for that conservatives
actually argued for in the past
and I think what we're seeing is
information technology
has shattered the brains of humanity
like I was saying before if you go back
to the 1800s what's a kid's morning
entertainment get up and help with the
chickens get up and help with the cows
so they're not seeing weird rabbits on
TV going
and the kid being like rabbit that's me
I'm a rabbit too
but then we start doing all this weird
stuff and here's I think about this like
early entertainment was like radio stuff
and so what was it it was stories so
these kids are being told be a soldier
be a cop be a doctor be a firefighter be
a superhero be Superman and then
eventually it turns into like wacky
broken brain families Peter Griffin I
mean I was not for kids but this is what
Society starts making somebody super
chatted Uncle Grandpa you guys ever
watched that show it's weird Uncle
Grandpa do you know what that means
if your uncle is your grandfather that
means your dad's brother is also your
dad's father meaning that
your grandpa had sex with his sister or
his daughter or his daughter that would
be his daughter right Grandma yeah so
wait if your grandfather wait wait it's
like I don't want it my father is also
your uncle that would mean your great
grand wait hold on
trying to figure this one out it's
complicated is it possible yes it is I
think it's something like you're uh if
your grandfather is your uncle
then
hit your your mom it's got to be your
mom I think that would mean that your
dad is your brother if your grandfather
is your uncle where'd you hear that
saying Wait no that's Uncle Grandpa was
a shell on Cartoon Network dad's your
brother right your dad's your brother
that's what that would mean what your
dad's your brother then your grandpa's
your uncle or is your mom your sister
yeah it would be it would be different
for different sex that's right you're
right yeah if a dude bangs his daughter
he's wait no no I don't think we're
supposed to know this is too dirty I was
gonna say I don't think you want to know
the answer but if your mom's your sister
then then your grandpa's your uncle I
didn't see a video the other day of some
woman jumping into a man's arms and
you're like oh you know it's gonna be
something the person's mother's brother
and father uh okay so that means
a guy would
bang his mom and have a daughter and
then he would bang his daughter and
would be your uncle grandpa
this is on Cartoon Network it was a show
on Cartoon Network I don't know if it's
still there anymore but like no it
stopped in 2017. yeah from 2017. you'd
be a person's mother brother and a
person's mother's brother and father
so that would brother and father be like
yeah yeah guy a guy so he has to be the
brother so
a mother
has a child with her son then the son
has a child with his child a female and
has you and now he's your grandfather
and your uncle gross yeah and your dad
gross one or the other probably what he
would be your dad too wouldn't he
brother and father
or no I guess he doesn't need to be your
father was it like science to everybody
science we figured it out was the show
sexual or was it just like a funny name
it was just weird it was a weird
absurdist kids show
but that's the interesting thing about
kids shows is they
look the kids shows I grew up on
Spider-Man X-Men Batman Batman Batman
the Animated Series think about what
this show is sure it's freaky but the
first animated show to ever win on Emmy
I think it was was the um Mr Freeze
episode is that it Mr Freeze really yeah
so uh I love the story man super
villains used to be one-dimensional yeah
I'm going to take over the world I'm in
Batman's like I will stop you but uh
with freeze he was a scientist to his
wife had a terminal illness and she was
dying and he was working on chronogenics
so is it cryogenics cryogenics cryogenic
freeze body parts to live longer so he
freezes her to preserve her life while
he tries working on a cure but he's
embezzling corporate funds to fund his
research to save his wife
when they find out and they come in
they're like you've been stealing money
from the company for this project and
shut it down he's like no my wife she'll
die you can't you can't turn it off and
then The Bodyguard smack they get into a
fight freeze gets thrown into the
machine or whatever it gets doused in
the cryochemicals lowering his body
temperature and then forcing him to have
to live in a lower temperature and so
basically freeze is a villain is
sad story his motivation is he needs
money and resources to save his dying
wife he's not trying to take over the
world and so Batman is like it's kind of
sad before that villains were always you
know not always like you had the Frank
Miller stuff and you had a bunch of
other interesting comics in the 80s
which led to this moment and then I
think it was the first cartoon so I grew
up on that I'm like watching this I'm
like wow villains aren't one-dimensional
you know and then with uh Spider-Man you
know it's it's similar stories but still
a little one-dimensional hokey villain
stuff
kids these days aren't getting any of
that it's all weird garbled nonsense I
mean don't get me wrong Looney Tunes
made very little sense too and I think
that stuff messes with kids Minds I'm
not kidding I think kids should not
watch that stuff what about South Park
South Park's not for kids political it's
cultural satire and comedy it's for
adults but kids watch I think kids have
watched it I watched it when I was a kid
like and it's warping that's very mind
warping but my but here's the thing my
parents had a parental control on the
cable and so I didn't watch South Park
all the time
my parents wouldn't let me watch Beavis
and button like we could watch it
sometimes this is what parenting is my
parents are back okay I'm gonna let you
watch one episode of Beavis and butter
because my mom would like know this
particular particular episode wasn't
that bad and then we would watch and we
would find it funny and stuff and
there's a disclaimer like do not do this
stuff at home because some kid burned
his house down from watching beef and
butter or something I was when I was
very young my parents wouldn't let me
watch MTV it was you know the new thing
and I was you know they were like no I
don't want you watching I've seen this
blah blah my mom used to believe that
like that she believed that uh she
believed in the the subliminal messages
in in Judas Priest stuff she's like you
don't I don't want you to listen to
Judas Priest I heard that man say do it
I was we were banned from watching Three
Stooges because it was too violent Tom
and Jerry because it was too violent I
was banned from Powder Puff Girls for
the exact same reason I feel like that I
feel like what you were talking about
Tim um is the Teletubbies and stuff like
that and the the cartoons are really
kind of more geared towards younger
people and when you're talking about
like the
um
the bad guys that that Batman was
fighting the more complex characters
like Mr Freeze and stuff if you look at
your average uh
environmentalist you know they have a
similar Outlook to
uh Thanos you know get there's too many
people there's we have to get rid of
people we have to have uh population go
down we have to control the population
and if you know there's not enough
resources on Earth and we blah blah blah
your average socialist uh
environmentalist is just Thanos without
the the the the glove is this Thanos
from the movie he actually wanted to
kill half the people for population
control he wanted to kill half of the
people in the in the universe this is
the real Thanos this is The Infinity
Gauntlet where the entire movie was
derived from this is the book and in
this he doesn't care about poppy all he
cares about is pleasing a woman that's
what the death it wasn't even a rule of
death yeah Lady Death he lost the police
so he kills half the universe but this
is that it doesn't hold on doesn't even
she doesn't even care we gotta make sure
you clarify not a woman The Entity death
yeah but he's in love with her the idea
her name is Lady death but it's the
entity of death it's like to say it's a
woman people might get the wrong idea
okay it's Lady Death we'll call her Lady
Death and she has the powers of death
it's it's the death God and after he
kills half the universe uh she doesn't
care and so he's like well now he's like
in an existential crisis of like lost
and the whole episode is the whole
series you got to read this series uh is
him like being lost being nihilistic and
having infinite power it's it's
excellent excellent there was some good
stuff they wrote in comics when they
started getting past the the
one-dimensional era and the weird era
like Superman could fire little Superman
from his hand do you guys know that yes
Superman had the ability to shoot
smaller Supermans
from his hand they were just Wilding man
they were just you know they were doing
acid and whatever they felt like they're
just like whatever man like think about
Superman freeze breath and laser eyes
like it doesn't even make sense in any
way I was thinking did it he used to not
be able to fly he could only jump yeah
he only jump and I think they they
didn't he didn't like in the early days
his powers were kind of random and all
over the place like the firing small
swim answer that's a real thing but we
have about we're gonna go to super chats
still in about 10 minutes but I guess I
gotta think about Andrew Andrew I keep
thinking about let's pull it up Baby
lyrics the story man Andrew Tate has
lung cancer
what leaked medical documents reveal now
they're saying does he and the report
people are saying is that he does
they say he has lung cancer he may have
lung cancer according to a letter
written by his doctor in in Dubai
the letter from Tate's general
practitioner at King's College Hospital
in United Arab Emirates suggests CB
repatriated to the gulf Nation
immediately the letter had medical
reports in English appear to be
translated into Romanian Tate is
currently in custody in Bucharest on
allegations of rape and trafficking hold
on there a minute he's never been
charged with any crime which is the
creepiest and weirdest thing about the
they're like when we when we suspect you
of a crime we lock you up for six months
is the information coming from that he's
his doctor his doctor yeah but it's
leaked you said right yeah and it says
he may have lung cancer yeah there was a
scan that found a spot on his lung and
they didn't get him in because they
think he has lung cancer uh I just want
to be careful here because I know
there's a lot of misinformation
um from both sides of fans and uh
detractors of Tate he is currently 36 I
know he smokes cigars but people getting
lung cancer in people younger than 45 is
extremely rare he's in very good shape
although he does smoke uh it it would be
very rare for him sure and you know what
maybe it's fake news but uh he's not
been charged with any crime so he should
not be in custody until they charge him
with a crime yeah do the right thing
guys release him because this is going
to be staying on Romania for a century I
already you know I was talking before
about how I loved brajav and Bucharest
and they were great places and I'm not
trying to go back to a place like this
it's disgusting look man you can
criticize agitate for a whole lot of
things and don't look at me I don't know
but to detain a guy for six months
without charge or trial like if he's
actually the villain you think he's it's
going to show itself you don't need to
but he's got to do it when these women
came out and said like Hey we're not
victims they're lying the judge goes nah
you're brainwashed like what dude if you
if a witness statement isn't good enough
and you're claiming the witness
testifying on his behalf is brainwashed
there's no justice system I'm not
particularly sympathetic to Tate's
stories uh like I I think that he might
have broken Romania I think probably
it's actually likely that he broke
Romanian law in the whole uh the what is
it the the sweet boy or whatever lover
boy lover boy thing uh charge him with a
crime yeah exactly 100 that's what
that's exactly where I was going even if
you know even if he did if he did do
something or if they suspect him charge
him so that way it's above board and and
allow the Romanian justice system to
take you know take its course but charge
him just holding him you know let him go
yeah or let him go that's fine too I
think um a part of this story is that
um Andrew Tate is becoming less and less
relevant as he's being held longer and
longer in jail because he's unable to
produce content and as that progresses
his relevancy decreases I think this
might just be a stunt to try to keep his
name in the media and the news and to
elevate this story more to try to help
him get out it did it concern me that
this is a desperate attempt to get him
out of prison it's attention because
it's diminishing because he can't make
content unless people are covering it I
don't care if there is a 0.001 chance
this is true
he should not be held without charge and
so it doesn't matter if they need to or
don't
this is all the more reason like think
about how insane this is if you're
suggesting the story is fake that would
mean that Tate's team is like okay he's
being charged with that he's being he's
been held in custody without charges
what scheme can we come up with to get
him released it's like holy crap you
shouldn't be in any custody at all
without charges I shouldn't need to do
this definitely he should not be in
custody and help being held without you
so why would they so so the idea I'll
put it this way if they are faking this
story to try and get him out of jail
good for them
good okay if the ends justify the means
yeah it's very thought about the
American Revolutionary of you yeah man
but but what you're the answer to by the
means in that the bad guy in this story
is Romania not the people trying to free
the guy who's being unjustly held I
agree that he is being unjustly held but
just specifically on the story here of
him having lung cancer right you know
that's what I'm talking about if a woman
is kidnapped is it like I don't know if
we should use violence against this guy
because the ends don't justify the means
like no no no no no no no the bad guy is
the person who kidnapped the person not
the person trying to figure out a way if
there's a guy who's holding someone kept
them in his basement and we're like the
only way to free this person is to sneak
in in the middle of the night break the
window unlock the oh that's breaking and
entering dude the ends don't justify the
means this is different if they have
dirt on him they need to bring the
charges and he needs to be brought in
for the judge and they need to show that
evidence I think in Romania I'm not
completely familiar with their legal
system but they have X amount of time to
hold him while they look for the
evidence which is weird and um I just
think they do it differently in real
media too which doesn't make it right
yeah that apparently is extension it was
the attention was extended 30 days three
days ago they said last week they just
extended it so like he doesn't even know
when they're going to release him
they're just like this lesion on his
lung by the way is from March of 2022.
um he got a health screening back then
and he was reassured at the time that
the mass was likely benign but is
advised to get further tests this could
be like the uh Joe Biden you know benign
skin cancer yeah we absolutely he should
have more tests I I just think look man
if Andrew Tate is innocent of these
accusations they shouldn't be holding
him and if he is guilty
and these charges these accusations are
correct they are losing the prosecution
against him by doing this they were
making themselves look evil and making
him look like the victim every day
they're holding him so all the only
outcome in this for Romania is net
negative the only logical solution is to
release the guy they shouldn't have
locked him up if they didn't have the
goods to begin with they shouldn't have
locked him up and it shouldn't be like
oh we're locking him up to find the
goods now I don't know I don't if that
is that the the way the legal system
works in Romania when you're accused of
a crime they will detain you and put
bring it and lock you up and then start
looking for evidence
that's insane I uh
Jessica was bad I don't live in Romania
I don't agree with their way of doing
things I think it is we in America we
have the right to a speedy trial we have
a right to a jury of our peers we have a
right to confront our accusers
and in Romania they're doing none of
that they're just like not like them up
extended period of time yeah that's
wrong and they're losing on it because
on the world stage as much as the
corporate press and their weirdo
cultists are going to be like Boo
understood's bad sure but they they're
not going to get someone like me and I'm
and I'm I'm ready to be like well he's
got a bunch of really awful videos maybe
these stories are true I don't care if
the stories are true at this point if
you have not charged them and you don't
have the goods to charge him detaining
him makes you look like the villain
innocent until proven guilty could he be
extradited by the US government I think
they're doing this in Romania they're
not like trying to bring him here on
things illegal they're trying to charge
him could the US government be like we
demand you release him back to the
United States he's a U.S citizen uh is
he a U.S citizen I think he is assuming
that he is could could the government
like they're holding an american guy in
uh against like in a detention that's
unconstitutional the United States the
U.S doesn't the U.S won't do that
they'll they'll allow the country to go
through their uh their justice system a
friend of mine Randy was uh held in
um where is it the Czech Republic uh on
trumped up murder charges
um because some kid jumped up on stage
and and he pushed him off and wait who
did Randy Blythe from Willamette God he
wrote a book about it it was six seven
years ago he was uh held in um in the
Czech Republic
um it might even be longer than six
seven years ago but he uh he had to deal
with all their with all their guys their
issues holy what's that the daily
wire sold 100
000 chocolate bars as of 8 47 p.m
just during the episode
in 12 hours 12 hours they sold 100
000 bars of chocolate wow damn are they
selling them by individual bars we need
to get on this game yeah dude tap in man
Jeremy got all the connections they must
have made a couple million bucks already
we're a hair care product man 100 000
bars Men's Hair Care yeah let's roll I
mean I'll do it with 100
000 bars yeah but how much are they
selling them for
let me check
wait what oh
I'm getting some weird security
restriction
I think we need to get in the beanie
game before we get into the hair product
game we're working on it a four pack is
25 bucks
all right so we're talking about like
what 25 it's like six bucks a bar yeah
that's before taxes I imagine
six dollars per bar all right I don't
care what anyone says Jeremy won the
club the culture War is Over Jeremy
boring won the culture War how much was
the daily wire because between Noel's
book with no words in it and Jeremy's
razors and the uh the chocolate bar if
you buy a 24 pack it's 100 bucks right
so that's what a bit cheaper a little
bit more than four bucks how much is
that Mr Beast bar
oh yeah yeah that's called uh feastables
right feastables feastables is pretty
popular he wrote daily wires is breaking
the cycle of lose bitchin boycott and is
instead creating actual Alternatives
feastables Jimmy where's your favicon I
still get the global icon you need a
cool favicon man
favicon yeah
man we got our our coffee coming soon
but uh I'm you know we're we're sitting
here trying to get this thing launched
since December and then the company that
we we work with is like it'll be done in
seven days and then they come back to us
after we sign and they're like six weeks
and we're like what
whatever it still is one of the best
companies we've found in terms of the
the product the freshness the delivery
the all the things they can do
and so we're like how did Jeremy do this
in 12 hours or not even in 12 hours in
like six hours like we're trying to get
when you got it you got it he's on
Century Duty right now if he sees a
company like just obliterate their
product with wokeness he's like call
them make them make the call Jeremy this
better be some good chocolate
you know give me the nuts give me the
nuts I want the almonds
yep all right let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com to
support our work directly we uh man
we've been ready to launch the coffee
brand for a long time we've got the
company building out uh uh we're working
on the contracts for building out the
the coffee shop and it just takes so
long this is this is ridiculous
man it's it's it's frustrating too as
much as I'm like it's really amazing the
daily wire pulled this off it is
frustrating to be like yo we've been
trying to do this coffee thing for a
long time someone I said in the s in the
comments if Jeremy's being mean in this
situation yes he is this is actually
this is uh how's he being mean well
because he's he's making fun of
Hershey's to make a point like yo this
is reality bro and uh I think people
will be like hey but he's not being
cruel he's he's he's not this is
justifiable meanness but look he's not
walking he's not saying Hershey you
disgusting awful evil he's going well he
said he's saying to you if you don't
like them I got a candy bar for you
right here the website's called I hate
her sheets so like that's mean you know
I don't I don't know I don't think about
you I hate Tim I hate I disagree what I
don't think it's mean to say you hate
somebody
mean would be when you when you seek to
inflict emotional harm
on someone to them I think that's
cruelty anyway I don't want to talk if
if if me and Phil were talking and I
said Phil
I hate John Doe I'm not being mean to
John Doe John doesn't even know I said
it but if you made a website I hate
johndoe.com and then sold products but
they're not saying it to Hershey you
know what I mean
they're not being mean to Hershey's
they're just saying it loudly right in
front of Hershey's Hershey's is going to
be okay I don't know I'm not a
that's not that her she has feelings
yeah liberations are not people aren't
they like even owned by like Mars or
something some massive faceless
Corporation I think Hershey will be fine
with uh you know we should do with their
website we should create an AI for every
corporation so Hershey's can have their
feelings hurt
I'm upset that people are saying that
mean things about me all right here we
go
what do we got
qatarth Swiss says can we keep the
cancer and get rid of Biden okay that's
a good one all right
I want to figure out a way to make that
happen all right I'm not your buddy guy
always with the first Super chats here
he says Tim check this out Douglas
already nuked the mainstream media
during his monk debates here in Toronto
Canada this past November very cool
Carrington Cox says no news with the
Tyree Nichols Affair rumor going around
but I'm going fishing with a buddy from
high school now an MPD investigator
interesting
comrade Nikolai says hey Tim and crew
anyone else think Biden is definitely on
his way out before end of term one and
Kamala gets shoehorned in
I don't think he'd make it past the
second term he's 80 now and with cancer
with cancer like you know these little
topical treatment type cancers but he's
getting old and uh I think he'd be 85 or
86 by the end of his second term if he
chose to run again I do not think there
is yeah but it's a it's not the bad
cancer like he's got cancer and it's the
well yeah but nine is the good cancer
and no there's no good cancer yeah
there's malignant and benign but neither
too good but the malignant ones are
cancerous the benign ones are cancerous
there's no such thing as a better cancer
it's like you have cancer it's bad yeah
this is the which bullet would you
rather get shot with question neither I
don't want to get shot but a little bit
of skin cancer is way less bad than this
if a crazy person would stand me in the
face with the Barrett M80 he had a bear
M82 or Ruger 10 22 and said you get to
choose I'd be like well I guess I have
to choose the Ruger 1022. I mean yes but
then that's that's I think it's
because if you get you know you don't
want brain cancer or lung cancer but if
you get a little I literally I literally
told you earlier that my dad died of
skin cancer you're not going to convince
me that a little cancer is okay you're
talking to the wrong dude
like was he taking chemotherapy uh well
there was there was uh there was therapy
that I'm not going to get too deep into
it but he did go through he went through
uh
um uh therapy and stuff like that um but
he didn't catch it until it was too late
he should have got it he should have got
it taken care of far earlier with my mom
I conversation I have a lot because
she's been diagnosed with like melanoma
for whatever it was for like 15 14 years
I'm like dude it's your diet get the
dairy out of the fridge stop eating meat
every night let your body heal you know
that's
that's I just don't take weird
pharmaceutical chemicals that you don't
know what they do I would I would I
recommend people listen to their
oncologists
Let's uh let's read some more we got
here Raymond g Stanley Jr with his gold
jewel encrusted beanie says Tim another
good culture War I really enjoyed the
new show Pete seems like a real nice
dude also I gotta acknowledge Phil has
been killing it thank you indeed yeah uh
check out the culture War podcast on
Apple and Spotify and wherever you get
your podcasts and it's at youtube.com
timcast talking with Pete was really
really great it's the first interview
he's done and it's been like a year and
a half since he was removed from the
band replaced and so uh I reached I was
like would you want to talk about it now
and he was like yeah I'm down let's
let's have a conversation about how this
all went down and what it means and uh I
think it's important conversation
because one of the one of the important
takeaways is how many people
this this is the big takeaway from the
show in my opinion
we used to be a culture of I am
Spartacus no I am Spartacus no I am
Spartacus now we're a culture of that
Spartacus right there that's him that no
no I'm that he's Spartacus don't look at
me I'm I'm I'm I'll do whatever you say
all of these people
fearing the government and and the the
culture cult are standing up and going
that's Spartacus arrest him arrest him
leave me alone I'm scared that's kind of
a terrifying thought to be honest
we every single story I hear about
someone standing up and saying I'm
Spartacus is followed by and then
everyone around me patted me on the back
and said thank you for being our Pariah
and I was just like geez man no one
defended you nobody stood with you
nobody linked arms nobody's nobody so
I've gotten I was in positions to be
considered canceled multiple times
because I have never been all that
careful with things that I say and no
one stands up and says oh hey you should
you know the people coming to your
defense they're not running and they're
not coming and and everyone is looking
to keep themselves you know keep their
own head above water I always think
about that with moms that speak out or
even that little kid that spoke out at a
school board meeting like it's so
awesome that he did it and it's great
that someone gives them praise but it is
always one-off little internet people
instead of you know the actual Community
around him being there being a part of
it instead they're like oh sorry like
that that upset the school board I think
we should stay away I've had a ton of
people in the metal community that have
come to me and say Hey you know I just
want to like Tim says you know he gets
people to talk to him and you know
they're just like they won't say
anything in public or whatever and it
happens frequently you know oh you know
I agree with you but I can't say this or
why would they say that and I made we
made mention earlier Sumerian records
that talked about the uh um the poke on
their on their Twitter account the other
day or yesterday or whatever and the
first replies were like why are you
doing this why are you talking about
this and it's like look man this is
where like the underground rock and
metal scene and punk and hard rocks like
that's where like the resistance to the
man is has is supposed to live remember
that uh Kaiser Chiefs everybody has
Clean Hands show me a hand you gotta see
that video that is so weird that video
is so crazy and they're like previously
they're all cheering
that's scary that's church that's people
losing well you said earlier like we go
to church to to get community I I don't
really get into doctrinal Christianity
as it stands but I love the community
aspect of it right well I think people
get that really wrong
um I don't I just personally think
people live in the idea that religion is
the same thing as relationship when it
comes to God and it's whack because
there's so many people out there that
think that in order to have a good
relationship with God you have to start
by uh following all of his rules because
that comes from the idea of oh God tells
me I must do X when in reality if you
read the Bible the way that God intended
you to read the Bible the reality is he
says if you want to follow my rules you
will like I'm not worried about it he's
not stressed about it he's not looking
for you to scold you like a mean father
guy's a homie I gotta say that guy is a
homie he just wants to love you and I
don't know who needs to hear that but
all right let's read this we got Stevie
Vivi says when Offspring released the
video for Let The Bad Times Roll I
thought I had an ally then they kicked
Pete and the lyrics quote and so I'm
turning my back on you change to the
song's theme
yeah
what a major letdown from that band you
know
major letdown all right what do we got
here let's read some more
Wyatt calledenberg says President Wilson
had a major stroke in 1919 and was
bedridden and could not speak for the
last two years of a second term his wife
ran the country for two years she passed
a lot of awful laws
interesting wow yeah that's likely
Ozzy says I'm pretty good at Impressions
I never thought Tim would be but his
Pelosi and McConnell Impressions crack
me up they really drive home how old
these people are but I just want to
stress they're not really Impressions
they're mockeries you know like I'm not
really trying to impersonate Nancy
Pelosi I'm trying to insult her
caricature
right slobbery caricature Robert Trump
is the worst Presidents we have ever had
Dentures are out yeah
and McConnell talks like the slow down
Democrats
there you go but you know Sheamus will
only ever give me Dr fauci I get I get a
message from Sheamus on Facebook and I'm
like oh Sheamus is like he's messaging
me again like you know I'm all excited
it's my friend he's not talking to me
and he's and it's a doc it's a Google
Document and I'm like oh he just wants
me to be fouchy that's all he wants
that's all he cares about
and so then I read the lines as Dr fauci
he can't even let me you know be Nancy
Pelosi Butchy making like a quiet exit
at the moment because I haven't heard
his name in the news if I understand
correctly yes he's trying to get out of
there somebody said Gross to my Pelosi
yeah that's the intent yes thank you
yeah and um
I can do a really good uh
Lori Lightfoot apparently
that sounds like Stitch it's Stitch
it's Gollum from uh Lord of the Rings
yeah
we should know no it sounds like Stitch
or Jacinda ardern
but I don't know if I could do Gollum
with a New Zealand accent I should work
on that one you got the world like uh I
don't sound like that but her mouth
looks like the only thing I can say with
the New Zealand accent is dext
that's pretty good like because that's
the only thing I remember
so I remember talking to someone in New
Zealand they're like just send me a dext
and I was like what
if you listen to their the uh the uh
prime minister that stepped down she has
got the thickest who's dealing accent
and I can't listen to her without life
that's the girl basically if there's any
politician who is in a state of decay
I'll just do gollum's voice and say it
to them
I'll take it
all right normies get out says just got
my Miracle beanie all the other beanies
are inferior blue beanies are feds what
at what do you know what what amount of
time you get the America one that's
that's like the longest isn't it yeah I
believe that's the longest I want to say
36 months wow so that's uh yeah that's
an OT guy right there
yep yep and we got to make more emojis
what do we have we have uh we added the
latest ones was the golden
that's my favorite yep
we wanted to do a premium tier of
ridiculous Emoji but you can't do it
either people are members negative
emojis or they can't you can't actually
make like a higher tier I guess because
we're going to be really silly with it
and make ridiculous emojis
all right T-Rex Pet Shop says Don Jr got
his account back because his bank faced
too much backlash thousands canceling
their accounts maybe Tim does Mr bocus
have a self-cleaning litter box you can
get one on our website he hates it yeah
he doesn't like to go inside of boxes he
really enjoys the open ones he's
claustrating so we uh I scoop it out
daily or Kara does I am I am glad to
hear that Don Jr got his account back
because I don't want to say too much but
let me just say we do business with PNC
and we had a meeting about
well I just we had a meeting about it so
if you know what I mean and we were very
excited to hear John Rich was opening a
bank and so let me just say we had a
meeting about it but if they did right
by Don Jr
then I want to make sure we encourage
doing the right thing you know I am with
you there except they didn't do right by
him they canceled his bank account and
they gave it back when they were afraid
I think that that's an indication that
they'll do it again in the future
perhaps but if we now all say we don't
care that you did what we asked we are
going to punish you anyway they'll say
okay then we have no incentive to
everyone yeah so we need to say thank
you PNC I'm sure it was all a big error
don't do it again and they'll say you
got it we won't Jeremy will probably
just make a bank for you guys so it's
okay he's listening oh man Jeremy I hate
pnc.com
are you tired of what banks that are you
down go to Jeremy's Bank we'll take your
money quite quite literally don't give
your money to people who hate you give
your money positive here Jeremy's gonna
come out in a week with Jeremy's Bank oh
no using ATM in the video
I mean that is actually funny he's like
don't give your money literally Give Me
Your Money that'll be great
all right
Zach Darr says Tim if you use the name
of the channel that appears on YouTube
and not the URL no one will be confused
about what channel you're talking about
it's Tim Poole
on on YouTube that's it if you go to
YouTube and search for Tim pool that's
the channel the problem is people get
different results and that's always been
the difficult thing like some people get
the Tim cast Channel and they think it's
the table youtube.com timcast news
shows the name as timcast and then
youtube.com timcast shows the name is
Tim Poole and I never did that one day
YouTube just took like they changed my
Channel's name from Tim Cass to Tim
Poole that's weird yep and I think they
like synced it with your Google account
it was something like that where they
were like your channel is now your name
it's been so confusing I've got two
accounts that are on with different
email addresses because when I made them
in 2008 you couldn't have two accounts
under one email address and now I can't
merge the accounts and then they had
Google Plus like they didn't know it was
just such a mess in the in the 2008 era
John Goodwin says dark chocolate is
extra nuts one of the ideas for Jeremy's
chocolate is a dark chocolate bar that's
just an extra large king size bar so
we're getting into race chocolate now
yeah oh yeah well that was the point I
was saying like body shaming call it
pitch black
no but you could do the body positivity
bar and it's just like a spattered
chocolate in an odd shape and it's like
don't hate it it's still delicious it
just looks weird Tim I don't understand
why um you don't talk about your your
poo chocolate bar why don't you just do
this
I think you should try to sell that it
was really good what about if it was
like a chocolate bar that looked like a
pregnant guy and when you bit into the
stomach there's like a little jelly a
white a white chocolate baby yeah what
if yeah what is that let's get creative
what if we just threw it on a whiteboard
what if
all right uh let's see oh God
here we go duloc says Tim I'm a 26 year
old blue collar worker I have been with
my wife for eight years I have a
four-year-old son with another one on
the way and hopefully my generation
isn't a complete loss I will be at the
Crystal Cove every weekend nice glad to
hear it
it's taking so long to do everything I'm
about to lose my mind I just don't
understand why everything takes so long
remember the process is the destination
bro we have been trying for a year and a
half the the new studio was supposed to
be done one year ago and it's been over
a year now I get it material supply
shortages we can't get the fiber
installed but I'm just like I gotta be
honest I know that if I stopped doing
this show and and went down and did it
myself it would all be done in a week
that's the most annoying thing about
everything yeah Phil's got this look and
I'm like I'm telling you bro I I just
think a week is is a little short
because I but I feel your pain I had
someone I'm trying to do some some work
on my house in New Hampshire and it took
a month and a half just to get the
architect to to do the measurements and
draw the the existing
plans not like the stuff that we're
going to change a month and a half just
for him to measure and give you the
plans for the existing house so that way
we can decide on the changes I feel you
we're going to build like a multiple
Faraday cage system where it's like a
cage inside of a cage possibly inside of
a cage but we need to get the materials
sooner than later because it might take
eight months for them to arrive I forgot
who came up with the quote but it's uh
if you want something done do it
yourself yep see Brett ain't dead in the
members chat says bureaucracy Tim no no
it's something else it's um I forget
what it's called but every step of the
way when a task is delegated to someone
else the amount of time it takes to
finish to resolve that task increases
that's just a reality so there's only so
much you can do
exponentially increases too as it goes
down to more and more people and then it
ends up with one person who's at the
bottom of the chain being like I'll get
to it when I get to it and then
eventually you walk in one day and
you're like what happened to that thing
I said and this happens a lot it's like
hey six months ago we were supposed to
do this thing whatever happened to it oh
I guess we forgot
the daily wire they're not forgetting
Jeremy's razors they're not going to
make their chocolate bars over there
doing something well a lot of this is
the economy screwed up like the coffee
stuff
it's just it's remarkable I don't think
it's any individual organization's fault
that every single company is dealing
with shortages and they're unable to
produce what we need from them that's a
reality of Biden's economy so that I get
but it is really frustrating that it's
like why are we having in order to get
the coffee shop up it's like once a week
there will be a 10 minute conversation
between parties and then they'll move
one inch and I'm like
why
like how is that possible are they
charging you for that no okay it's like
you'll meet they'll say we gotta do
measurements then they'll say next week
Thursday we can come in and do the
measurements they come in for 20 minutes
to do the measurements then they say
okay uh next week Thursday we can give
you the schematics then we say okay then
they come and give it we go over it we
say this got to change okay give us a
week to change them and it's just like
it's insane and I'm ready to be like
I'm ready to go to a thrift store and
just buy a bunch of garbage stack it up
around the walls and put an espresso
machine from Best Buy in there and be
like shops open and then from there we
can every week add a new thing and build
up that's the annoying thing about how
how trying to build a business and then
open if we get the floors done we could
do that
I I honestly the building's there it
exists I'm ready to just like open the
door and be like we serve nothing we
don't have any permits you hang out and
I'll I'm not even kidding we'll hire
someone to just stand there and like we
can put up some tables and y'all can
play board games or something maybe you
should get like six things building at
once so that they all start staggering
in and getting completed
we'll start with a tape with a with a
folding table for 20 bucks from Walmart
I'll buy a couple hundred dollar
espresso machine we won't sell the
espresso because we don't have the
permits but you can have some if you
want
and that's where we'll be for now
you can hang out we'll put a TV and
video games in there I'm not even
kidding I'm ready to just do that I'm
not even joking
um it's been since December
that like and every day it's like oh now
there's another problem you know I'm
done with problems I'm dumb talk I'm
done talking about it I'm ready to just
get someone to go nail a TV to the wall
put it put the mounts up we'll stick
we'll stick a switch under it and y'all
can play Mario Kart all day it's there
people should be hanging out
is there a working bathroom yes there's
like six yeah then you're good yeah
bathrooms work
there you go Wi-Fi will help but no
Wi-fi as long as you get the bathroom
actually no I think we do have Wi-Fi
then you really have very few things
limiting you
the I guess the issue is it would just
be like
a non-permitted space Oh permits yeah
yeah but if we're not selling anything
it doesn't matter like people are
allowed to come into my building it's my
building I own it come in hang out play
board games
I think it's a good idea oh before no
coffee before coffee coffee's free free
coffee free coffee and we'll just get
like some store-bought don't do it until
it's ready don't do it until you're
gonna start selling stuff because you'll
start incurring a loss immediately
things with damage we already are that's
the damage that incurred by traffic but
that's that's a reality I'm just saying
this we open those doors and let people
come in and then all of a sudden
magically things will start getting done
everyone's like well you know we'll be
another week
no uh oh no actually we have a show on
Friday you have until Wednesday to get
it done or you're fired and they're
gonna bet okay we'll get it done
it's this is the crazy thing about
everyone I've ever worked with it's like
you tell them hey we need this done by
tomorrow it gets done the day after you
say okay fine two days is fine then four
days later they're getting it done and
then if you give them four days to do it
okay I understand it's really stressful
so you need a week then three weeks
later it's done you got to be like if
you don't get it done you're out bye
yeah I find people respond extremely
well to say Thursday by four o'clock you
have it done and if they don't reprimand
that's the way because people if you're
like get it to me whenever if you need
an extra day it's gonna take whenever
people need deadline a lot of people
need deadlines because deadlines are are
the motivating factor for an enormous
amount of the population if you tell
people that there's no deadline that's
open-ended they're going to do things at
their own pace if you give them a
deadline and they say okay then they've
agreed to it then they'll stress that
they've said yes they've agreed to that
time so they've they internalize that as
their own commitment and they're like oh
man I gotta blah blah blah or at least
they're more
so here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna check and see if it's possible
but here's my idea
Mount some TVs
bringing some sofas we'll grab them from
a thrift store who knows I don't care
then uh if you're a member of the
website you can come and hang out and
we'll start with that front door will be
uh will be like it'll be locked you
knock someone will be there and they'll
be like howdy and you're a member of
timcast.com the but yep but let me pull
up your account boom nice to meet you
John welcome come on and hang out it
might end up though that three months go
by and you're like just paying employees
to stand around and it's just incurring
loss after loss and you're like dude I
kind of hired three people for this
I I you are incorrect I mean if you're
not selling anything uh-huh so we are
already losing money on the people
sitting around because we have to have
people there as it is you can't have an
empty building so why don't I just let
people come hang out because then it's
going to be like okay people are here
you need to start figuring out ASAP
like the building's not empty we have to
have people working there all the time
and so all we're doing is everyone's
sitting there right now being like well
you know when it gets done it gets done
and I'm like nah not anymore I'm opening
the doors
open the doors you know we'll open at
the nine and we'll close at nine or
whatever and we'll I'll hire a guy I
mean bro if I hire some you know someone
who's a fan for like 15 bucks an hour to
hang out play video games all day I
really don't that's not the big big of a
loss and I think that investment will
actually get things moving faster
you're gonna have people coming in and
they're gonna be hanging out and it will
start something this is the problem with
traditional brick and mortar stuff you
invest a large sum of money to create
the foundation and then once it's done
and everything's beautiful you unlock
the door and then cross your fingers you
get your money back but I've always said
the way that the way I like doing
business is just start doing it figure
it out and build it as you go which
would mean at this point I'm done
waiting it's been four months I'm
frustrated the coffee's taken four
months and this company let us down and
so I'm just like I'm sick of it you know
like the crazy thing is I've been
talking about this fact checking
non-profit and it's like well it's going
to take another x amount of months to
register with all the different states
and I'm like this is insane that it
takes so long to do this I I think I
trust your instincts I think you do
things different than a lot of people
but that's fine you're successful so
yeah I think we should just start by
being like it's a club it's a private
building for private members members of
timcast.com you can come and hang out
whenever you want and then once we get
the first floor done with the actual
coffee bar and the plumbing and
everything the then we'll open those
doors up to the public with the permits
and everything and the club moves to
floor number two and then ultimately
Club is floor number three just starting
is probably a good idea because that's
that tends to be the thing that uh that
that slows people down the most is
waiting for the right time being like
well you know we don't have this or I
don't have that or I don't have this
particular thing she's going and being
like all right we're going to go and do
it we'll make it work that's a that's it
gets things in motion gets things going
so I don't think it's a bad idea
yeah I think a couple people working uh
15 bucks an hour and their job is
literally just to hang out like I could
get someone who's in school and be like
do your homework
be here
unlock the doors order food
do your school work play your video
games and that's your job you're just
here to basically like watch things and
then we'll have a club and people can
come and hang out and ain't nothing in
there the chat's yelling you have to
have liability insurance first we do we
have every we have all that the problem
is it's like the contractors to build
everything out it's getting delayed and
now it's been three months how has it
been three months we can't get someone
to put some two by fours with a big old
plank of wood on top of it
grant that we need Plumbing that I
understand to do the you know and then
but we're not even like at three months
we should have at least had a plan for
the the machines we're gonna get the the
coffee supply has been delayed and I'm
like you know what man I you know the
purpose of the place isn't to sell
coffee and make a million dollars
selling coffee the purpose of the place
is to create a community Hangout
you can do that in a building so I'm
just like I'm ready to open the door
we'll figure it out I'm sure I'm gonna
get some lawyer or someone being like
well now listen Mr Paul I I understand
your frustrations but you've got to take
into consideration
that's how it always goes someone's like
hey here's breaking news we got sued
several times I'm not supposed to talk
about that either
there you go happy Friday everybody the
news is broke yep yeah someone I was and
when I was telling you about hey it
might cost this amount of money
someone's like Ian Tim just bought two
grand and candy bars too bruh
but but that that was that was in direct
support of the daily wire coffee and
stick what they're doing and uh I want
to support what they do I want them to
do more of it I want people to buy their
bars I want more people to do exactly
what they're doing speaking up speaking
out and engaging in culture in this way
I want those candy bar rappers to have I
want to spread that culture I want
people who come here to be like what's a
he him bar I'll be like don't you know
about what the daily wire did
the culture building can't just be one
company doing it we have to actively
engage with and spread the culture
building so that's what that's all about
that's what I want to invest money in
that's why I want to spend money on the
cafe and when you walk up to the counter
to buy your coffee there will be a he
him she her bar from uh from Jeremy's
chocolate and then we'll be like that's
a large coffee and would you like to add
any Jeremy's chocolate to your coffee
purchase and uh actually yeah I will
take one which one is the nuts oh I get
it
all right so yeah we'll we'll try and
get that stuff done thank you Stanley
Junior says Tim say yes I'll drive down
hook up the TVs move furniture and no
charge teamwork we will be reaching out
to you Raymond g Stanley Jr and then
maybe we just make you captain of the
club because you're basically captain of
the club as it is uh and Waffles but uh
we'll figure it out all right my friends
yeah a lot of people are saying
procrastination all right if you haven't
already would you kindly smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com because I'm
basically trying to make it a
multi-faceted thing you are supporting
our work you're supporting the website
but what we're going to try and do and
it may not work out this way because one
of the things I'm learning
each different venture has to be its own
entity so the the club it's it can't be
for Tim cast members because it has to
be separate for liability reasons so it
will be its own separate Club but we'll
figure out a way to make these cool
things because what I would like to do
is create a One-Stop shop where if
you're a member of timcast.com you get
all these benefits
but I think for liability reasons we
can't it has to be like the physical
space it has its liabilities its
insurance and as a company it has to be
responsible for its own income so we'll
figure something out though because
uh it yeah no definitely has to be
separate we are we already have issues
with the fact that we have a skate park
in this building with people who are not
skate park related it causes insurance
issues you could do an umbrella Corp
like Google owns YouTube so if you have
a Google account you can use your
YouTube without so what so if you made
like x-corp then it could own with your
x-corps we we can't have a corporate
insurance and then add on a separate
building that does a totally separate
thing because it would conflict with the
insurance it has to be a separate entity
what if xcorp owns this The Entity of
the car the liability transfers up to
the parent company
yeah so separate companies there's
there's
we'll figure it out anyway become a
member at timcast.com we're working on
it uh Chrissy do you want to shout
anything out yeah if you want to go
follow me over at the reaction on
Chrissy Clark or also our documentary
that I was talking about earlier damage
the transit of America's kids you can
find that at
damage.dailycaller.com and people can
follow you on Twitter yeah at Chrissy
clerk underscore
thank you so much
hey everybody thank you guys for tuning
in I'm a journalist here my name is alad
aliyahu you could follow me on Twitter
at alad aliyahu and my work's also
posted on the timcast news Twitter and
website but make sure to follow us at
timcast news on Twitter
I am filled that remains philabonti the
vocalist for All That Remains uh
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
you can find me on Twitter at fillet
remains on Instagram at Phil That
Remains
official yeah I'm eating across some
fall media and Crossland and be cool to
your siblings if you have them you're
very lucky so take advantage of that
tell them you love them and you know let
yourself love them
I like that uh follow me on Twitter at
Kellen PDL thank you guys and have a
good weekend check out the culture War
podcast with Tim Poole and app on
Spotify if you have the time over the
weekend it's a two-hour conversation
with Pete Parada formerly of The
Offspring talking about vax mandates
what it was like in the music industry
what it was like for him he tells a
little bit of his backstory and uh we've
got more awesome guests for that show
coming up and if you uh if you want to
check out uh check it out it would be
greatly appreciated thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all Monday